Good Lord.
Here we go.
Hey everybody.
What's cracking?
How's everybody?
How's the weekend?
Big Kiss.
We'll start out.
Start off with a big cast.
This episode of the podcast brought to
you by new sponsor.
It's called Ziprecruiter.
Ziprecruiter is a um,
it's a website that if you're hiring
people,
it allows you to reach the most
qualified candidates.
Are you hiring?
Do you know where to post your job to
find the best candidates?
Posting your job in one place isn't
enough to find quality candidates.
If you want to find the perfect hire,
you need to post your job on all the top
job sites and now you can with
ziprecruiter.com.
You can post your job to 50 plus job
sites including craigslist,
linkedin,
and twitter,
all with a single click.
Find candidates in any city or industry
nationwide.
Just post once and watch your qualified
candidates roll into ziprecruiter's.
Easy to use interface,
no juggling emails or calls to your
office.
Quickly,
screen candidates,
rate them,
and then hire the right person fast.
Find out today why ziprecruiter has been
used by over 200,000
businesses and right now my listeners
can post jobs on ziprecruiter for free.
That's right.
Free you cheap bitches.
I feel like I don't want to spend money
on this.
Well,
you can try it for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/Rogan.
That's ziprecruiter.com/Rogan.
And you can try it for free.
Ziprecruiter.com/Rogan.
Enjoy it and find the correct candidate
for the job you're hiring for.
We're also brought to you buy naturebox.
Oh,
yummy.
Yummy naturebox.
I'm sitting here in honor of our guests
care,
Santa Maria,
who's from Texas.
I'm eating the Lonestar Snack,
Mitch mix mix in that yummy stuff.
Mostly violence.
A lot of America.
It seems like it's mostly nuts.
Do you want me though?
I'm naturebox.
Gives you a ton of delicious choices.
Uh,
hundreds of different choices.
Really yummy stuff.
Peanut butter,
nom noms.
If you had those yet.
Pretty God damn good.
Dark cocoa almonds.
We have those baked sweet potato fries.
I had those.
Good,
Yummy,
yummy.
I haven't found any SRIRACHA cashews.
I don't know what the fuck is going on.
There might be some sort of a shortage.
I talked too much about the cashews.
Seriously did.
They were like gone off the website for
a bit.
They are that good.
Naturebox is pretty fucking bad ass.
It's an excellent way to get healthy
snacks delivered to your home and if you
have like specific requirements,
like if you want snacks that are low on
sugar or non Gmo without gluten,
they have all that stuff.
They have all their snacks have zero
trans fats,
zero high fructose corn syrup.
So they're very delicious and you don't
have to feel guilty about them,
especially if you choose correctly.
Big Apple Pineapple or big island rather
big apple pineapple,
like growing pineapples in New York.
The fuck is wrong.
That's what happens when you fly.
And then you try to talk.
Your brain is like,
what'd you do to be stupid?
But Big island pineapple,
really delicious and simple simple
stuff.
The um,
those,
uh,
blueberry almonds too.
I can go on and on and on.
There's a lot of different choices from
naturebox and you can have nature box
shipped directly to you for free if
you're one of those people that works in
an office and you're tired of going to
that vending machine looking for a snack
and just choosing the the most healthy
out of everything that's not unhealthy.
You can do way better.
You could do way better with nature box
and if you go to naturebox.com
right now,
you're going to get 50 percent off your
months first box,
so go to naturebox.com/Rogan
and you will get 50 percent off your
first box.
Naturebox.com/Rogan.
Yummy,
yummy stuff.
Enjoy it.
Go try it out.
I guarantee you'll find something that
you like.
Last but not least,
we're brought to you by [inaudible] dot
com.
That is o n n I t on it is a human
optimization website and what we sell
primarily is things that we find that
well,
mostly things that I use,
things that we find that benefit you,
whether it's strength and conditioning
equipment like our kettlebell series,
the Zombie Bells and the primal bells,
which are these artistically created
kettlebells that are all three d
balanced and maps,
so even though they look cool,
they function just like a regular
Kettlebell.
If you've never used any athletic
equipment,
I said this ad Nauseum,
but I have to have to repeat it because
I don't want anybody to get hurt.
Please start slowly.
You do not have to kill yourself the
first day.
If you're one of those people that
hasn't worked out for years and you're
like,
digit,
I'm going to work out like a fucking
monster from now on and the first day
you work out really hard and you hurt
yourself.
We'll that's not good,
right?
That's not good.
Which you want to do is start slowly and
just write things down.
There's a lot of people in this world
could benefit from writing down things
that you want to accomplish.
Write down a routine,
a simple routine.
Real simple.
Today I'm going to do 20 pushups,
20 sit ups,
and I'm going to run a mile.
You can do that.
It won't take that long.
It'll probably take like an hour to get
everything done.
Maybe what's,
what's a strong mile,
seven minutes.
You're not going to run seven minute
miles.
We'd never run before.
He probably been run 10 minutes,
so that's,
you know,
it's enough time.
Just get a little exercise in folks,
do a little something.
Get your blood pumping.
It's fucking good for you.
We also sell healthy foods and
supplements like the new warrior bar
that we started selling it on it,
which is a all natural buffalo bar,
14 grams of protein,
no antibiotics,
no added hormones,
gluten free,
very yummy.
And it's done with this old lakota
recipe that um,
the,
they use cranberries and it's actually
quite delicious.
And like I said,
140 calories,
four grams of fat,
and it's a two ounce serving with 14
grams
of protein.
Excellent for you.
All this stuff at on it we sell is all
stuff that either myself or Aubrey uses
and we find the very best things as far
as like protein supplements,
as far as you know,
any,
any of the items that we sell,
we just try to find you the best shit
that we can go to.
Onnit.com.
O n n I t used the Codeword Rogan and
you will save 10 percent off any and all
supplements and there you have it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Poom.
Kapowwe.
Whalley.
Kara,
Santa Maria is here.
Why fuck around Brian.
Cue The music maybe already on.
Brian likes to fuck around with new
operating system.
He may have loaded some new operating.
Says to Mondo was fucking fucked up.
Why don't you just sing it as a ticket
out?
You had it working on it.
What happened?
He doesn't even know the music.
This is Lulu.
Lulu is operating systems.
Not.
What's this one called?
Yosemite.
It's called Yosemite.
I thought they were like cats and shit.
This is so good.
Carrie.
Santa Maria is here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
my friend,
Brian's friend.
Jamie knows her well,
be friends eventually.
What's up?
How are you?
Good to see you go to um,
tell my,
my facebook followers that I'm on right
now.
But there's so many different.
Joe Rogan's don't want to click on the
wrong one.
Which one is Joe Rogan?
E Net.
What the fuck?
Dot Net?
No,
but like on your facebook,
which one is your actual.
Are these all just people trying to.
Mostly they're not me.
Yeah,
there's like 100 fake music.
If someone's tagging fake job,
someone sending you some Dick Pics,
I guarantee you that's not me.
I guarantee you even it looks exactly
like my Dick.
That's not me right now.
I have the sweet talk nerdy tee shirt on
right now which represents Kara Santa
Maria's.
Awesome podcast.
How many episodes do you have now?
I just put up episode 26.
Jesus.
Louisa,
can you believe that?
Number one,
you were number one and I do it weekly
and you,
you inspired me.
You and your listeners inspired me to do
this.
Well,
you're,
you're born for this.
This is a perfect venue for you.
I'm telling you.
Thank you.
By the way,
but I'm telling you when I left your
studio the last time I was on,
I probably got 300 tweets from people
saying,
start your podcast.
It's awesome.
It was great.
It was so great.
That's so cool.
You already have 26 of them.
That's incredible.
How did you do that?
So fast?
He just do them weekly and it's been
that long.
It's been 26 weeks,
so it's been six months essentially in
March or April.
That's awesome though.
That's so cool that you did it.
You,
you need something like this because you
know,
whenever you deal with a lot of
producers
or you know,
network folk think they mean well,
but they all,
everyone has their own idea of what
should happen and even if they're nice
people it gets in the way.
It's so true.
And like I,
you know right now I contribute to,
to different television shows and I'm
very lucky I'm a freelancer.
I'm a contributor so I work on a show on
Al Jazeera America called Techno,
which is a great science kind of news
magazine style show.
And then I work on a local show here in
la called soquel connected,
which is on Kct,
which used to be our pbs affiliate and
now it's just a,
um,
a public television kind of standalone.
And that's great.
I have great producers.
I get to self produce some stuff.
It's wonderful.
Prior to only doing those and the
podcast,
I was full time on a show called take
power,
live on pivot TV.
That was daily eight to 12 hours a day
every day,
you know,
hair and makeup for two hours straight.
Basically two hours.
Yeah.
Was trying to turn you into a werewolf
saying absolutely didn't look like he
wasn't allowed to wear my hair straight,
wasn't allowed to wear black,
wasn't a law.
It was crazy.
Like I couldn't have rules.
Very strict.
I could not be myself on that show.
And I look back and that is really when
the podcast started because I was so,
like you said,
kind of boxed into speaking only in
sound bites and presenting a version of
myself that honestly I was not
comfortable really presenting the
podcast was a really,
really necessary outlet.
Like it was so psychologically freeing
for me and now I think it really helps
keep me centered and anchored when I do
new jobs and new work to really
understand how not to let things get out
of him like that.
The best representative of yourself is
yourself.
You got a bunch of people like deciding
what you should do.
I think it'd be great if you wore pink.
Oh look what you should be in paint that
legitimate like I did.
They made me wear pain.
Like it was crazy and I had to wear my
hair out curly.
I read it and they hated that and I
don't know,
man.
I think it's because I was the only girl
on the show at the time.
It was like very male heavy and I was
supposed to be like the representative
of the female species,
which was like,
come on.
I'm kind of a tomboy.
Like it wasn't really working for me.
It was a lot of short skirts too.
Which is weird for me.
Like I like to wear black leather,
but yeah.
Anyway,
and we've talked about it many times in
the podcast about how you watch Fox News
and all those women who like,
it's almost like they have it in their
contract that they have to uncross and
crossed her legs like a certain amount
of times per minute because it's like
who the fuck is that uncomfortable that
you're shifting and switching your legs
back and forth and if a man dressed like
that,
it would be so insane.
Oh,
can you imagine saying because there
are,
you know,
if you watch runway shows ever,
you keep up with fashion at all.
There are kind of male versions of that
sort of ensemble,
but nobody actually.
Where's that in real life.
Like the short kind of tight,
maybe not up to
your nut sack,
but like halfway down your thigh,
these little like plaid shorts and then
he will,
you know,
it's very runway,
but even those are shorts.
There's something crazy about a skirt.
Yeah,
I agree.
I mean it's just like easy access.
It's the most ridiculous invention.
It's like your vagina,
which is your coveted sexual organ.
I mean,
this is like,
this is where the babies come out,
this is where you let the loved ones in
this so much to the vagina and yet it's
there protected by the thinnest piece of
fabric.
If,
if we've seen all these little teeny
bopper celebrities and their little
woopsies getting in and out of cars
oopsies where there just happened to be
cameras right down near the vagina is
like,
that's not a website.
Such shit was engineered.
What's the reasoning behind that?
I should have a cooter.
Why would you want to do that?
Some people want to look at it.
I don't want that to be Clark Clark with
me.
I'll never forget what he said about
vaginas because he's of a different
persuasion.
He goes firsthand saw vagina.
I was like,
when's it going to heal?
But it is a weird thing.
I mean that you're presented as a
serious journalist on Fox News or as a
neuroscientist,
which is what you are,
and yet they want you to have your
vagina basically just barely protected
by a little,
a little napkin that they throw over it.
No,
thank you.
And always the cameras are,
you know,
right at the midlines,
the midline of the table and so it's,
it's just like an unflattering or,
or ultra flattering depending on how you
look at an angle that just makes you
feel really exposed.
It's.
Yeah.
How are you supposed to take somebody
seriously?
That it's.
It doesn't make you any hotter.
That's where people are confused.
Yeah.
You don't have to.
I think it's a little better sometimes
to leave things up to the imagination.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
no it's not,
but I'm saying like maybe not on tv,
on the news news.
What's your.
Yeah.
What's your objective?
I mean,
is it better in real life?
Well,
no.
Well I don't know.
Depends on what you're trying to do,
but if you're on a show where you're
just trying to like talk about issues,
it's distracting.
It's distracting to have like this
really sexy outfit on and I think that's
half the reason why these fucking Fox
News type shows do that.
Barbara Walters never dressed like that
can be corrected,
but she,
you know,
not too too scandalous.
But she did wear short skirts and I was
actually just watching,
so I'm gonna get a little more
comfortable.
I'm very short and I feel tiny in this
chair.
Um,
so I'm just crossing my legs.
So I was watching this documentary
called misrepresentation.
Have you seen this?
I'm about to get like super feminist on
the show really early,
just so I can piss off like everybody on
twitter.
Um,
so actually really good documentary.
It's called misrepresentation.
You can find it on Netflix and it was
produced and I'm kind of narrated by
Jennifer Siebel newsome,
who Gavin newsome's wife and
the whole thing is kind of about media
representations of women,
how women are portrayed,
how women,
you know,
make up x amount of the population,
x amount of the jobs in this field and
this field and this field and then how
they're represented both in fictional
television but also in nonfiction
programming.
And they talk a little bit about that,
kind of why our female news readers
meant to look.
So I'm sexy.
It's always kind of like the crusty old
dude.
And then like his hot and nice,
like that's what it looks like when you
look it up,
a news reading team,
um,
and,
and they have these great interviews
with people like Lisa Ling and Katie
couric and kind of talking about Katie
actually is very open and says I kind of
feel guilty like almost I played into
this like maybe I set this trend in
motion and um,
you know,
I was fit.
I wore,
you know,
not ridiculously short skirts,
but you could see my legs on TV.
And then it seems like that's now the
formula that every news reader has to
have.
And you almost just assumed that they're
dumb.
Like it,
it,
it portrays.
I,
I don't think it portrays strength.
Unfortunately.
When you have these girls that are women
that look like they're trying so hard to
be sexy,
then all of a sudden it puts it in your
head like,
oh,
she's just reading a script that
somebody else wrote for her.
When sometimes these are really,
really bright,
really successful women.
Like why do you want?
Or just they just want people to watch
it and they just feel like the best way
to hook people is sex.
Yeah.
And,
and the truth is they also,
in the documentary,
they showed all of the major news
corporation,
which there aren't that many anymore,
you know,
they've been kind of conglomerating and,
and uh,
more and more of the property is owned
by less and less people and they showed
the number of women on the board,
on the board of all of these different
news organizations.
And so you look at like Time Warner or
you look at Viacom and it's like one
woman,
two women,
you know,
to women and as opposed to like 30 men
are 15 men.
The people that are making the shows and
the people who have ultimate control
over those kinds of decisions
historically and to this day are like 99
percent male.
I wonder if that's why I like women like
Megan Kelly,
that Fox lady who's not at all,
she's very sharp.
She's kind of mean,
kind of got an edge to her wonder if
it's like to like let you know,
hey fuck face.
Just because I've got my tits hanging
out in my legs are crisscrossed,
barely covered my cooter.
I'll still put you in your place where
she's on her heels all the time.
I'd always backed up.
Yeah.
I don't think it's an uncommon feeling
for women who are just in a position
where they're surrounded by men who just
are going to assume when they walk in
the door that she's just dumb bimbos
she's a weather girl.
She's a news reader,
but really she's writing her own copy
and doing her own research and it a
really strong smart.
I mean,
I disagree with like fucking everything
she says,
but I've seen her be a total brilliant
on air before.
She's slightly more rational than most
of the people in that network.
That's not saying much because she can
be pretty rational,
but she,
you know,
she's right wing.
That's just,
that's her thing.
She's like a real Santa Claus is white.
Is that her kapow she's hot as fuck.
That's very distracting,
right?
It is.
But it's also usually looks like that
on.
That's what you should do.
Just fucking work it all the way deep.
Ridiculous.
She should do the news from a bed all
day.
All the news should be done from silk
sheets.
She's got her tits highlighted.
Yeah,
she does.
They're different colored.
Yeah.
That's an interesting.
I mean,
come on,
wardrobe,
dry.
She basically has a two tone thing with
the tits or impossible to not look at
because they don't blend in at all.
And that's the thing.
It's like they really push you.
I remember on um,
take part live one day wearing one of my
favorite looks,
which was like black pants,
high heels,
a white button down shirt that was
fitted.
I mean I think that the outfit was,
I consider it like a hot outfit and a
black tie and,
but I had my hair braided and kind of
pulled back and I was wearing glasses
and my producer told me that I couldn't
dress like that anymore because it was
too masculine.
Look like a girl.
Like it's obvious that I'm not trying to
be a dude.
I like to wear ties.
Producer guy.
No,
no.
You don't have to say no,
he wasn't.
It wasn't.
No.
Maybe he really was.
No,
he wasn't for sure he wasn't where he
thought you look masculine like that.
No,
I mean,
I dunno.
It's like put on a short skirt and and
you get that thing to where even if they
don't overtly tell you,
it's like you get off air every night
and when you're dressed in an outfit
that you love,
like pants a shirt,
like you feel comfortable but you feel
good about yourself and you look in the
mirror and you think your body looks
good.
It's like whatever.
Okay,
fine.
Show whatever you were like the dumbest
little short pink skirt or dress that
you're totally uncomfortable in and
you're not acting like yourself.
You look great to know like in your ifb,
like in your,
in your ears,
because they're constantly,
they're like in your ear,
like that's gross to the ifps are gross.
I know it's horrible having someone talk
to you,
especially if you're in the middle of a
conversation and they're difficult that
or don't say this or bringing this back
and bring up that are asked this.
It's tough.
Especially when there's tension between
you and your producer when not hiding
it.
When I do post fight interviews,
when I first started doing it,
they used to talk to me in my ear like
way back in the day,
like sometimes it'd be in midsentence
and there'd be some fucking clueless
shithead on the other end.
You know,
it hasn't happened in decades because
then the new guys are awesome.
The guys that have been doing it for,
but in the nineties when I did it,
there would be a guy talking.
I literally had to take the thing out of
my ear because I couldn't concentrate on
what I was saying and they have a
meltdown in the booth when they see you
take it out of your year.
I don't know what it's like.
You can't.
You literally can't form a sentence.
First of all,
when you're doing post fight interviews,
you're doing it in real time off the
cuff,
completely ad libbed and you're.
You're asking questions and adjusting
based on how the fighter talks to you.
They don't understand like even a good
producer will be like,
well,
I never talked to you while you're
talking.
I wait until you stop talking.
It's like,
yeah,
but I have to fucking hear with the
person I'm interviewing says to me,
you literally can't hear you.
Someone to talk to you here and you're
talking.
I don't hear it.
No,
you can't hear it all and it's,
it's the same thing that show I was on
was a live show every night,
so I get it counting down to commercial.
The things where you have to keep time.
Hey guys,
we gotta wrap it up.
We've only got a minute left.
Great.
But like just the talking and the
talking or you should say this.
It's like fuck you.
I'm not going to say that to say what I
want to say.
Well that's the beautiful thing about
the Internet.
You know,
the beautiful thing about the internet
and producing your own show and creating
your own show is I kind of look at those
old shows,
the shows that have been around for a
long time like that.
Especially those news type shows we
talked about like the the uncle and the
niece and the like,
that kind of weird format where they
talk fake and it's everything.
Seven minutes cut to commercial.
I feel like that's a dinosaur.
I really don't think that's gonna.
I mean I don't think it's going to last
for people,
sort of our generation.
I use that loosely,
but I think most of middle America is
still watching that kind of traditional
television in America gets the Internet
two.
They do.
That's true.
America is not middle America anymore.
I think most of middle America,
I mean they're.
They're watching what's on because it's
always been there,
but people are way more hip.
Yeah,
they are.
But tell him when you go on the road,
don't you feel it,
Brian,
when you go to Ohio and all these
different places like that used to be
like a little behind.
They're not really behind anymore and
there's a lot of fucking slick people
that are living in the middle of
nowhere.
Yeah,
absolutely.
I think that's what's great about
everything.
I mean,
I just got rid of cable from my first
time in for once.
I'm like choosing what I want to watch
instead of just like,
oh,
what's on TV right now?
So you're kind of directing,
but what are these Middle America people
picking out?
Stupid Shit.
Like I wanna watch this.
Slowly but surely though they're getting
more hip.
No,
I think so too.
I think part of the problem though is
that,
I mean you look at the statistics and
Fox News is still the most watched news
network.
Like what does that say about our
country?
What says?
First of all,
they don't really know what the fuck
people are watching because the Nielsen
ratings are ridiculous.
That's true.
It's the most antiquated way of figuring
out.
It's the only thing that's worse is the
arbitron.
When they try to figure out who's
listening to radio,
that Shit's ridiculous.
I could give you a book and you're
supposed to carry it around and write
down.
When you listened to this channel,
when you listen to that channel like
they don't fucking know.
What ends up happening is that people
represent themselves to be different
than they are.
They're like,
I love NPR when they like never listened
to npr because they think it looks good
as well.
There's that thing that they do on
networks as well where they'll.
They'll like,
if you're on a talk show,
especially the.
They have the ratings based on how many
people are watching up into a certain
point.
Like that's why the tonight show has a
20 minute break because 15 minutes in is
when they do their first rating so they
don't want to cut to commercial because
then you'll change the channel fuck up
the ratings.
So they have this 20 minute things so
everything is geared towards like keep
watching us,
look at us.
We're going to do something crazy and
they just.
It's like sweeps every night duties,
do anything to try to get you to hang in
there for 20 minutes and then they'll
bring someone on and that's what the
skirts are all about and that's why you
have all these people that their
sensibility is not based on what's the
best way to get caris thoughts out.
What's the best way to get megan's
thoughts out?
The thing is,
how do I get someone to watch this
chick?
Oh,
completely.
And also there is a problem I think
where people say,
okay,
well people in the industry,
especially when you talk to them about
this,
they go,
well,
whatever.
We just give people what they want.
So you look at like bad reality tv where
there's cat fights and humiliation
television and all the shit that,
you know,
the Kardashians,
all the shit that we're like a breaks my
heart that this is so popular in
America.
And then people say,
well that's what the people want and
we're just answering to what their needs
are.
You know,
we're not actually effecting any sort of
social change.
We're just playing into the hands of,
of,
of what they're interested in.
But I say that that's fucking bullshit
because we have an illusion of choice in
this country.
Like we don't have viable options.
If I want to watch the news,
I've either got Fox News,
MSNBC or CNN.
Those are the things that are easy for
me to find.
I probably,
unless I haven't expanded cable package,
don't have al Jazeera or BBC World News
or another option or rt or another
option available to me.
So I'm watching this programming that's
no longer even news.
It's just fucking advertiser blow jobs
and like ratings run offs.
You know,
our team,
an interesting example is kind of a
fucked up channel that rt is very like
in the one hand there's amazing
reporting happening there and in the
other hand it's like answers to the
Kremlin.
It's so weird.
Abby Martin is a friend of mine.
She's been on the show several times and
she's great and she's one of the rare
people that can kind of dress however
she wants.
She dresses,
she wore slacks should wear.
I mean she's very pretty,
but she'll wear,
you know,
she'll wear something that makes it look
hot and then if that's what she wants to
wear or she'll wear something different.
But she has a weird situation there too
where she's criticized Russia,
like especially what's going on in the
Ukraine and you know,
and they were like,
we're going to send you to the Ukraine.
And she's like,
Whoa,
the fuck you are like,
no,
you're not sending me to the Ukraine.
They like made a publicly or press
statement because she was,
she was criticizing Putin's
administration and what,
what was going on and you know,
was very public on television.
She did this thing and so they said,
we're going to send her to,
to Crimea so she can see what it's like
on the ground.
She's like,
Yo,
you're fucking mind.
I'm not going to a war zone.
What did you guys,
you didn't talk to me like,
you know,
this is not happening.
I'm just telling you right now.
It's not happening.
But it's weird.
It's a weird place.
I've,
for Russia,
I'm pretty good friends with um,
a loaded mankowski and Jenny Churchill
who used to work at rt on the aloneness
show back in the day and then they went
over to huff post and we're at huff post
live,
which is,
um,
where I kind of met them.
And that's where the science editor.
Yeah,
that's where I was their science
correspondent.
There was a science editor in New York.
I did all their correspondent,
like on air work,
um,
and so I met them there and yeah,
they've told me some pretty interesting
stories too about our t and a lot of
stuff has been leaked lately,
like you see it,
like the reporters there have been more
and more open about the fact that
there's an obvious agenda at that news
network and I feel like when it comes to
Russia reporting you have to take it
with a huge grain of salt,
but they do a good job of investigative
reporting in other parts of the world.
And also what's interesting is everybody
that knows about our t primarily knows
about it from clips that were released
on the Internet.
Yeah.
They,
they're really good about their social
media and videos.
It's a big reality when it comes to all
those new shows too and all those
tonight show and talk shows their,
their whole thing is get a clip that
pops it completely.
Something that you could put on
television and the or put on television,
but then people will make a clip of it
and put it on Youtube.
I mean look at Snl,
obviously people still watch it if you
want to believe Nielsen ratings,
but like that show is not good anymore.
It hasn't been good in a really long
time,
but they really reinvented themselves
with the digital shorts a few years ago
and as those were getting released,
I mean there was this new kind of
resurgence of young people being like,
oh,
snl is actually funny.
It's not so kind of worn out and old.
Yeah,
it's the whole problem with this and
there's a bunch of problems but trying
to do a new show every week and then
just doing it live in front of an
audience.
Just a terrible idea and they don't have
any.
It's like make it a half hour show.
Like don't make it an out.
Because what ends up happening is they
have good ideas for clips and then they
just,
every,
every single sketch,
they just run it into the ground.
It's just like they get the joke and
then they repeat it 10 times.
It's also like a super competitive
environment and you know Phil Hartman,
who was a good friend of mine,
we were on Newsradio together and he was
on Saturday night live and he had a
nightmare stories like after talking to
him about what it was like the
backstabbing and all the weird behind
the scenes shit that goes on.
People trying to force their,
their sketches in and other people cock
blocking them.
It was just like,
oh,
that sounds horrible.
Worst thing,
the worst way to come up with something
creative.
Like they have this like weird
competitive environment.
Like no one's supporting it.
I mean,
I don't know how it is there now,
but he told me some nightmare stories.
Yeah,
there were times when it was really
amazing,
but yeah,
there was.
There were some times Eddie Murphy days,
there's,
you know,
I mean it's,
you're always going to have talented
people who are capable of being funny
under extreme circumstances can put them
in the worst scenario and they could
figure out how to make something funny
occasionally,
but you're right,
like it would be better if it were much
looser,
but it's TV.
Be Better if they had time,
like you need to work on a sketch like a
once a month sign and drive specials
would probably be a fucking nuclear
bomb.
That was really bad.
That's true,
but people have these expectations and
they want to live up to those
expectations and they want to keep up
with the ratings and make enough money
and all the old school
tv model is I,
I don't know how much life it has left
in it.
The problem is that's where the money is
still.
It's a legacy model.
It's all of the investors,
all of the advertisers.
It's how they know how to do their jobs
because they've been doing it for so
long that they still pumped so much
money into that machine.
I mean,
I see it as a freelancer when I get
offered a TV job.
It always pays better than a web job
across the board.
That's where the money is still in,
in and.
And that's where my agent is trying to
push me.
I do a lot of web work because I like
new media and I like that.
I can be free on it,
but the truth is we're still in this
kind of legacy world with,
with old school media and until those
large corporations start to understand
new media,
I think that you're going to see this
weird inflated bubble where all the
money's still stays there,
but nobody's even fucking watching
anymore.
It's adjusting.
It's adjusting slowly.
But it's,
it's,
it's definitely,
uh,
in this transitionary period where more
people are kind of realizing,
hey,
isn't everybody on line?
Everyone is online,
right?
So isn't it aren't the same people that
are online also watching television
shows like we can reach them in both
ways and then it will slowly shift.
In my opinion,
it's going to shift to the Internet
almost entirely.
I really don't see.
The only benefit that I could see a
networks is things like game of thrones
where you need massive budgets to put on
these spectacular special effects and
everything in Ireland.
You know what I mean?
So I think you will be able to see and
what happens when those production
companies or when Hbo Rolls Out and it
becomes a standalone app where you don't
need the cable provider anymore,
then fuck,
that's online too.
I mean,
the only things that I appointment view
anymore at all on television are masters
of sex.
What does that?
Um,
it's on showtime.
Oh,
is that the Kinsey thing?
Well,
it's masters and Johnson,
so different researchers.
But yeah,
sex researchers from the fifties.
So this is like that movie was Liam
Neeson.
Who the fuck
is that the Kinsey movie?
Yeah.
So,
so the Kinsey and then I don't remember,
but Kinsey and masters and Johnson are
probably the most cited sex research,
historical sex researchers in psychology
courses where you learned about sexual
behavior,
but masters and Johnson a really
interesting thing because masters was an
ob Gyn.
Johnson was his research assistant and
they fucked a lot and that's show.
And so they got.
They were the source of a lot of their
research.
Yeah.
And it's Lizzy Caplan and Michael Sheen.
It's really good.
Is it?
It's a great show.
That's interesting.
So is it,
is it a pervy show?
Is it Kinda like a.
well,
there's a lot of scientific about their
socks.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
they totally are.
But it's a new field at this point.
Nobody has thought to investigate like
sexual response.
So they are the first people to detail
what happens when you have an orgasm.
They're the first people to try and take
measurements of female orgasm,
like all these.
Really nobody thought that that was
legitimate research at the time.
So he gets thrown out of multiple
institutions.
He's always getting
in trouble.
It is pretty fascinating.
We think about it.
It wasn't until the 20th century that
people started researching stuff.
Oh.
And sexuality.
And even then it was all men,
like nobody gave a shit about a female
response.
That was totally secondary.
Like because this is what happens.
This is another little feminist.
I'm a soapbox.
Is that feminist though?
I have an issue with the term feminism.
I know it's kind of like,
it's the term feminism.
All it really means is that I support
equal rights for women.
You know?
So in that sense of the term,
yes,
I'm very much a feminist,
but so were you.
So it was probably everybody in this
room and of the people listening for
sure.
And so this is the thing when you don't
have female physicians and you don't
have female researchers because the
institutions don't allow them,
then you don't have a female research
perspective.
So all of the sudden all of your
research subjects are men because nobody
thinks that it matters to research what
happens to a woman's body.
And it took decades for research on
female sexual response to catch up to
research on male sexual response,
which is crazy because females are the
child bears.
Yeah.
It's pretty bizarre.
I know.
We're pretty bizarre when you think
about all the different things that used
to be used on women,
like the women used to go to a doctor to
get manually manipulated to orgasm
because they were like suffering from
hysteria,
hysterectomy,
hysteria.
They all connected.
Like that was the idea.
And you know,
in women who would go to hospitals for
exhaustion,
that was like a common thing to Austin.
She's hospitalized for exhaustion,
which is celebrities still do that.
Precious.
They say,
yeah,
they say that,
but it's like it's either depression or
substance abuse.
Right.
That's what they used to call them,
exhaustion and it was only women,
wasn't men that were going to do it
sometimes too,
but it was very common for housewives to
go in for exhaustion.
Wow.
What they do to.
I'm just check them off,
just they might've.
They might have and they probably gave
him like early versions of psychiatric
medications and they basically let them
leave whatever stressful environment
they weren't.
Get away from the babies that were
making you depressed.
Get away from the husband,
go be on your own for a bit.
Read a fucking book.
Do you think it's fair to think that
as life becomes easier and as a society
and civilization is more like goods are
more accessible?
It's easier to get food.
It's easier to get water.
It's easy to get services and then
slowly but surely things sort of
equalized in terms of the more
aggressive sex males paying more
attention to the needs of the female.
But in the old days when things were
much harsher,
people lived less that they have a
shorter lifespan.
The world was a darker place than it was
more sexist.
Do you think it was more like men were
just like,
look,
this is,
these are tough times.
Fuck off bitch,
you know,
I'm going to get mine.
I think it's probably both.
I think that there's definitely,
you look at kind of maslow's hierarchy
of needs you've ever studied
psychology,
hospitalized for exhaustion make you
look at maslow's hierarchy of needs and
it's like this pyramid.
It's like the food pyramid,
but it's the needs pyramid and at the
bottom are things like food and water
and shelter.
Like when you're concerned about food
and water and shelter,
you're not concerned about things like
love and um,
friendship.
And then as you get to the top,
it's things like self actualization and
Blah Blah Blah.
So I think that there is a component of
yes,
if you're just struggling to survive,
contemplating or waxing philosophical
about it,
you know,
civil liberties and things like that,
it's not in your.
So you may be very instinctual and you
may be aggressive because of that or for
whatever reason you may see kind of
patriarchal lines that are drawn in the
sand and some sexism and some violence.
But I think on top of that,
maybe that would always be the case.
So long as women didn't have a voice.
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure if just moving to the
future and I'm not sure if it has a
function,
if it's a function of people having more
access to food and goods and services or
if it's really a function of women.
Because what happened was women were
mothers and men said,
okay,
mothers bring life.
This is something that we should respect
and we should honor.
And this was a historical norm for a
very long time.
And then as you know,
these kind of hunter gatherer societies
moved into more agrarian societies and
started to form cultural structures.
Men realized I can overpower that bitch,
like I have physical strength and I can
physically put this woman in her place,
and as they realized that there was a
power differential between them,
that men were physically stronger.
I think that's where a lot of
patriarchal wisdom comes from is that
men are physically stronger than women.
Do you think that wasn't there was there
was realized not until there was
agriculture and until there was cities
and I think that that was a big part of
it is when you think that that would be
a big part of it everywhere.
I mean all primitive cultures.
Well if you are a hunter gatherer type
and so you're living in a very small
tribe and you're concerned about kinship
or the welfare of your children,
then I think that there's a certain
amount of respect and honor that you are
going to pay to your wife,
but why does that go away with
agriculture?
Why does it go away with the city?
It's not so much agriculture as it is.
All of the things that come along with
that agriculture,
which is maybe political power,
which is starting to stratify and have
jobs and,
and it no longer are you making your own
clothes,
making your own shoes,
doing your own hunting,
doing your own cooking.
All of a sudden now you're a cobbler and
you're a butcher and you're whatever.
And so people have to depend on one
another for goods and services and they
have to say,
okay,
I'll trade you this for that.
And then money comes into play and
bartering and all of a sudden,
whereas it was a lot more egalitarian
before where
everybody kind of had a strong role
because they were taking care of
themselves or they're very small groups.
Their family groups.
Now all of a sudden they have a place in
society.
And that's I think where you really
start to see a subjection of women is
because men start to develop power
within societies.
And if you look back historically,
there are no known societies that were
matriarchal societies,
but you do see in smaller kind of tribal
communities,
more matriarchal,
um,
ideology more kind of honoring and
worshiping of mother figures and mother
gods.
But every time there's a society,
it becomes patriarchal historically,
throughout every time.
There's no such thing as those.
Yeah,
all of it.
There is no such thing as those
Amazonian women tribe that,
you know,
people talk about like the Amazonian
women.
That's your girlfriend.
Yeah.
And that's not a real thing,
like women are going to take care of
them.
It's a myth.
So their vaginas.
So,
and I don't know,
I can't say that that's a cause of it,
but those things are highly correlated.
But do you think that that evens out
once civilization society becomes more
complex and has.
So my,
my point was that scarcity makes people
desperate and when people get desperate,
they victimized not just women,
but they've victimized week.
Exactly one week.
It's like you know who,
who were the people that we historically
look to for like heroic figures in times
of great stress when people that pulled
themselves up by their bootstraps and go
out there and kick some fucking ass
people with big muscles.
So I mean that's the thing.
It's,
it's such a brutish and such an
underdeveloped,
a way to value strength,
to only value strength in like I punch
harder,
right?
Because there's other forms of strength,
but you're right,
when people are desperate,
people know that,
that,
you know,
think about if you're having an argument
with another guy or if something comes
to a head even at work,
wherever,
and you're having an argument and you
can't agree with each other and you
start to get more and more frustrated.
What's the way in every film,
in every I'm a book.
What's the way that it finally get
settled?
You roll up your sleeves and you get
into a physical altercation with each
other,
which is just not a form of strength or
not a form of,
um,
of settling a score that's common in
like feet.
In females it happens.
Don't ever watch basketball wives.
Yeah,
it happens.
They throw it out like the worst of the
worst to.
Not Normal.
It's counterintuitive,
but the best way to avoid that with men
is martial arts.
Get men in a situation where they train
and they compete against each other on a
regular basis.
They don't have this need to dominate
each other the way it's true because I
do think that it's a bit stupid to to to
just completely ignore the role that
things like testosterone play in gender
dimorphism like in female male
differences in humans and and other
higher order mammals like testosterone
is
a is a chemical that actually is highly
linked to things like aggression and
feeling tension and having this need to
release that in some way and we have
less of it.
We have significantly less of it and
some women are more aggressive in.
Some women are completely passive and
are never aggressive that way,
but there is a significant difference
between males and females and
testosterone is a big reason for that.
So being able to get that aggression
out,
whether it's on a heavy bag or whether
it's through martial arts or whatever
exercises you use,
I think it's irresponsible to think that
that's not part of the equation.
Yeah,
it definitely is for a man coming from a
male point of view.
I know it makes a significant difference
with me whether or not I can release it
or not,
but it's also the just doing martial
arts and being involved in something
that gives you an understanding of what
physical confrontation is really all
about it.
It doesn't.
It's not this scary thing that every man
has to like puff his chest up to avoid
happening or.
Or you go into it completely ignorantly
thinking it's like a movie,
like you're going to sock some guy and
that's going to be the end of it and
meanwhile you throw a punch at him and
he moves his head and you're like,
oh shit.
This guy actually knows how to fight.
Now I'm fucked because now I tried to
hit somebody that is not going to let me
hit them.
They're going gonna beat me up.
A lot of that I think comes from fear
and it comes from ignorance.
It comes from other ridiculous,
these media depictions of what happens
when people hit each other.
One the things that drives me fucking
crazy and I really wanted to talk to you
about this because I wanted to get into
depression is a head trauma.
Like there's so many God damn movies
where someone hit someone in the head
and they fall down,
they get up and they rub their head and
they were out cold and then they go out
and they fucking have a crazy fistfight
with 100 people or you know,
they,
they make it like they're back to
normal.
Like they get shut off and they come
back to normal and that's fine.
Guy Is like,
you know,
this great martial artist is,
is in a fight with like 10 other dudes.
Right?
And then he's like punching and kicking
and then he does that thing where he
headbutts like tons of like cracked his
skull against the skull of like multiple
people in a row.
And it's like in no way affected by it.
Well,
headbutts,
it's really weird thing,
but the way to do it correctly,
it actually is effective because you're
using this part of your head,
your forehead,
which is a really hard part and you
smash them in the nose and your nose
kind of gives in so crazy,
but it works.
It works like crazy.
I wish we had a shot of redband just
then when there's a great video of a
woman knocking a guy out in a bar,
this.
There was some sort of a bar fight in
This guy was involved in a fight with
this woman's boyfriend and the guy grabs
the woman and the woman grabs the guy
shirts and slams him in the head right
on his nose and the guy goes out cold
and goes limp and it's hilarious because
it's like this little woman and this big
man and she knocks him out with her
head.
Yeah,
but that's that.
They never showed that in the movie.
They never hit him in the nose.
They hit him like in the same part of
their head.
Yeah.
You can't do that.
Well you can.
You're going to scramble your brain or
Samoan if you're like one of those dudes
with extra big head,
you can get away with that,
but for most people you smash him in the
nose.
I mean,
you probably don't want to do that too
much.
We're even seeing that there are just a
video.
This watch.
This girl had bought this dude.
It's fucking hilarious because there's
all this shit going on and this girl
just grabs this dude and Kaos see if you
can cut to it because it's kind of a
long video.
If I remember correctly.
There's like a lot of shit going on.
Big Bar fight.
Oh,
just isolate it because this is.
Is he punching her?
No,
I think.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Dude.
That's insane.
Yeah.
I don't know when in this video.
I don't think this is the same video.
I think this is a different one.
Yeah.
This isn't the same video.
The other video was indoors.
That one,
that one's outdoors,
but whatever.
Um,
yeah.
Like even,
you know,
they're finding that soccer players,
just the multiple,
the movement of like hitting a ball with
your head over and over and over and
over and over causes mild concussive
injuries.
So yeah,
cracking people in the skulls a lot is
probably.
Yeah,
it's not really avoided.
Well,
you know,
and me,
I've obviously I come from this
background of not just constantly doing
that my whole life,
but being around it my whole life I've
been around so many guys getting hit in
the head and I've seen them from the
beginning of their career and then I see
them at the end of the career and I see
a significant decline in how they
communicate and how I'm sure how they
feel.
They seem like old men when they're in
their forties and depression is a real
issue and it's one of the reasons why I
wanted to bring this up is because my
friend Mark Gordon,
Dr Mark Gordon,
who's an expert in traumatic brain
injury and he works a lot with soldiers
and athletes that have had significant
brain trauma and they have a lot of
issues with their hormones afterwards.
The pituitary gland is extremely
sensitive and he wrote a piece
connecting Robin Williams with
depression,
not just based on a lot of factors.
I mean robin had a lot of things going
on and he,
he obviously had substance abuse issues.
He obviously he had the Parkinson's
issue which was also taking medication
for Parkinson's,
which has been connected to depression,
but he also had heart surgery and his Dr
Gordon's connection was that Robin
Williams having had this major heart
valve replacement,
which entails many hours of anesthesia,
lowered blood pressure and the
literature speaks of post cardiac
surgery,
depression and over 100 publications and
that the prolonged surgery with low
blood pressure,
they believe precipitates a perform a
form of she hands syndrome,
which is the loss of important brain
hormones.
Oh,
interesting.
Additionally,
there is an increase in reverse t three
and a decrease in t three,
which can cause a relative
hypothyroidism that's also associated
with depression.
And Mark Gordon wrote this whole piece
about it and he's saying that what
people have to consider more is like
when you take someone into a situation
where you're fixing their heart,
you're,
uh,
you also have to realize that there's
gonna be some adverse effect.
The whole body's gonna react to this.
It's not just gonna be about,
look,
your heart's fixed,
you know,
why are you so sad?
You know,
hormones are fucking completely out of
whack now.
And that could have played a factor in
this that was ignored.
Well,
and that's something that I think that
we've historically had this really weird
approach to medicine,
which I think is kind of a secondary
effect of thinking scientifically.
And obviously I,
my background is in neuroscience.
I worked as a scientist for many years
and I am very much a scientific thinker
and I'm all about the scientific method.
But I think that we sometimes are at
fault when we're a little bit too
reductionistic and our views.
And so if you look at the history of
modern medicine,
of evidence based medicine,
what ends up happening is that we look
at a problem and we try to fix the
problem and we look at it as if you can
somehow cut that piece of the person's
physiology completely out of them,
solve it,
and then put it right back in.
And it doesn't have any effect on
anything else in their bodies.
I mean,
you look at medication,
right?
Um,
any,
any form of pharmaceutical,
they all have side effects.
If you think about what a side effect is
it,
it comes down to how medication works of
medicine is a molecule.
It's some sort of molecule that fits in
a receptor somewhere in your body.
And the idea is that you want it to have
really high efficacy.
So let's say that I'm somebody who has a
problem with blood pressure for example.
Or actually let's just jump into
depression because I've been talking
about this a lot lately around Robin
Williams.
I had Paul Gil Martin on my podcast just
last week to talk about that.
He,
he hosts the mental illness.
Happy hour podcast and has really great
insights into mental illness and I of
course publicly have dealt with
depression most of my life.
I take medication every day.
I go to therapy every week.
I'm very open about it.
Isn't that for a lot of people,
they would look at you,
especially people that don't have any
issues with depression.
They look at you,
obviously very intelligent,
beautiful young.
Why would you be depressed?
Guys probably tripping over themselves
trying to date you.
You,
you.
You're obviously very successful in
pursuing intellectual pursuits.
Why would you be depressed?
For a lot of people are like,
why would a lot of people don't
understand the difference between
depression and sadness and they don't
understand that depression is a
biological illness.
Know they don't think of it and they
also don't think of it in terms of like
people look at it in terms of like,
well,
you've got all these sums.
Looks like you've got all this,
these numbers.
Look,
there's all
that almost can can make it worse for
certain people.
I mean,
you look at somebody like Robin
Williams,
he had so much going for him right?
He was famous,
he was loved,
he had all this money.
How could he be depressed?
He didn't have the problems that you
were I have and you know what?
Then you have this extra layer of guilt.
You have this extra layer of shame,
this extra layer of why the fuck am I
still depressed?
No matter how much success I get,
no matter how much money I make,
no matter how much people write me
letters and say that they love me and
and whatever.
I can't seem to beat this feeling inside
of me.
This constellation of symptoms because
it's not coming from that.
It's coming from your brain,
isn't it?
I don't suffer from depression,
but I have had many friends who do and I
have always wondered what it's because
it seems to be that when you go to a
doctor and they start treating it with a
treat it with medication or they try to
adjust your diet and prescribe exercise
first,
that there's no like one simple fix and
everybody's completely different.
We'll get people get upset about that
because I think it goes back to,
to kind of what I was talking about
before,
which is a meandering way to,
to.
Okay,
so again,
to go back to this idea of a drug,
you take a drug,
let's say I take an antidepressant.
My antidepressants specifically is a
selective serotonin reuptake inhibitor,
an Ssri that's called citalopram.
That's the off brand.
I think it's Selectsa,
um,
is the brand name I take that it binds
to my serotonin receptors in my brain
and it allows me to dump more Serotonin
into the synopsis that the gap between
two brain cells so that I always have
more available.
It basically tells my brain that I need
more serotonin so I make more serotonin
available to myself.
It's a,
it's a real uptake inhibitor.
And so I'm sorry,
it keeps more serotonin in,
in the gap,
um,
instead of sucking it back into the
cell.
So I always have more available to me
now.
It's a molecule.
It's got a shape just like anything out
there.
It has geometry,
so it binds to this specific receptor in
the brain because it had got a similar
shape to that.
There are other things in your body that
are similarly shaped and so what ends up
happening is when you take a drug,
the specificity of the drug is only
based on whether or not the key fits in
a locked somewhere in your body,
but let's say that you had hundreds of
thousands,
millions of locks available to you and
one key and you started going through.
You'd be able to stick that in a bunch
of locks.
Some of them it might even turn,
but it would fit in the lock of multiple
locks hanging on that wall.
So what ends up happening is I take this
drug,
it binds in my brain,
it does what it's supposed to do in my
brain,
but it also may be does other shit like
makes me really fucking tired or it
makes it so I don't want to have sex as
often.
It's a side effect and the reason that
you have a side effect is because
there's other parts of your body that
the drug binds to.
It's the same thing with medicine.
Like you were saying,
you operate on somebody heart.
The heart is connected to other things.
It's it,
it's the source of blood flow throughout
your body.
It is connected to hormone levels.
There's all sorts of things that can
happen when you put somebody under under
anesthesia,
when you them open,
when you,
uh,
you know,
you,
you cause an immune response and
inflammatory response there your body is
a holistic thing and so when you start
jacking with certain things,
other things are going to happen.
That doesn't mean you should throw the
baby out with the bathwater,
but medicine is a risk benefit analysis
always.
But how do they find the.
It seems to me that they find the right
medication by experimentation that they
try it.
And is that just the only way?
It's because we don't have any test.
I can't.
You can't go up as a doctor.
You can't come to me,
stick a needle in my spinal cord,
take out my cerebral spinal fluid and
measure how much serotonin I have in it.
I wish you could.
I wish I could take some sort of a blood
test or I could,
you know,
pee in a cup and then you could analyze
that p and say you're low on Serotonin.
You need an Ssri.
That would be what works for you because
other people's depression comes from
problems with dopamine,
comes from problems with norepinephrine
or some combination thereof.
But there's no test for it.
It fucking sucks.
There's no test for it.
And so what ends up happening is you
have to play a musical chairs.
You try a drug.
Maybe it was the first drug I tried for
aunt,
uh,
when I decided to finally go on
antidepressants,
fucked me up so bad.
I took an n,
d,
R I a selective serotonin norepinephrine
and dopamine reuptake inhibitor.
I was so fucking depressed.
I couldn't function.
And we decided,
let's throw the book at it.
Let's take the drug of all drugs,
the monster drug that does everything.
And I couldn't sleep for a week.
I felt like I was on straight up crank.
Like on crystal.
I quit smoking,
I quit smoking.
It was awesome.
That's when I quit smoking.
That's an important point.
Terrible for your body.
Horrible.
Did you do anything to try to naturally
stimulate your body to produce more
serotonin?
Did you try a lot of exercise?
Did you adjust your diet but you didn't
quit smoking?
I did.
I mean ultimately you've got on the
drugs,
didn't trust only on the drug for a
week.
So as soon as I got off the drug again,
I immediately wanted to smoke again.
But at that point I'd push through it
and I said,
you know,
I'm,
I'm at my lowest.
I was at my lowest point I've ever been
at.
So I was like,
fuck,
it can't get any worse.
And I did.
I quit smoking and it's been a couple of
years.
But I did,
I tried.
But the truth is,
this is why addiction research is so
important.
This is why researchers go into the lab
with a bunch of mice or whatever and
they feed them a bunch of cocaine and
they,
you know,
do these different kinds of experiments
where you,
you've heard of the famous experiment
where you have the mouse in the cage and
it's got a bar pressing paradigms that
can push the bar.
It gets coke and then like it just
fucking does that until it dies.
Like it.
Like there's food right next to it and
it's like,
no,
I want more coke,
and then it just dies.
And so the.
Obviously there's something happening.
This is a natural phenomenon because
mice don't have value judgments.
They're not thinking about this from a
religious perspective.
They're not saying,
I don't know,
maybe I should stop doing this coke and
maybe exercise a little more and that'll
give me the same kind of high.
It overwhelms.
It's
such a strong addiction.
Nicotine have the same sort of addictive
properties are more addictive.
Nicotine is nicotine.
Natural in the natural form is not like
nicotine as far as like pipe smoke,
nicotine is still addictive.
Even if you're talking about like vaping
it or something like that,
and I'm talking about like the,
like traditional methods of it,
like the way they would smoke tobacco in
a pipe or a cigar or something.
It's not as addictive.
I don't think it's as addictive,
but it's still addictive.
I mean it's still,
it's the nicotine is the molecule that
studied in laboratories.
It's not the tar,
it's not the shit that comes in the
papers now.
That's what has much more carcinogenic
properties,
but nicotine itself is highly addictive
and that's the molecule that studied in
research.
It's pure nicotine.
Nicotine itself.
It doesn't actually have some medicinal
benefits.
It does.
It's actually neuroprotective so it can
protect against Parkinson's.
Wow.
So if you smoke you won't get
Parkinson's.
Well,
I wouldn't say that,
but there is some evidence in the lab
that animals that were given nicotine,
um,
had a lower incidence rate of
Parkinson's.
Is it,
is it dangerous in the form that people
take it as far as like gum or things
along those lines as much less
dangerous,
but the goal still would be to get off
of nicotine because the reason they're
chewing the gum is because they're still
addicted to it,
but is there a way to take a small
amount of it that gives you those
neuroprotective properties but it's not
dangerous?
Possibly.
I'm on,
but I think it would be important for us
to see more research to see how.
How you know,
again,
it's a risk benefit analysis.
Like is it really that beneficial?
I don't know.
It's hard to say what's the dose
response curve?
How much would you have to take for it
to be beneficial?
The thing about depression that is
fascinating to me is that there are some
correlations between how well your life
is going.
Do you have relationships?
Do you,
are you happy with what you choose to do
with your day?
I had a friend who was a.
He was on like some serious a SSRI and
they changed his life.
They got him.
He,
he quit his business.
He quit his job,
brother started his own business,
got involved in relationship,
and then once he got to a really good
place,
he slowly weaned himself off the
antidepressants and now he's great.
Yeah,
and that happens to a lot of people and
so I think that there's different.
What we have to understand too is of
course all psychiatric disorders or
spectrum disorders,
right?
There's really extreme examples and
there's barely any examples and if
anybody who's ever taken a psych course
or who studied,
you know,
if you were a psych major in college,
you know that as you've studied the dsm
four,
which is,
it's called the diagnostic and
statistical manual that they use in
psychiatry and psychology.
It's basically the big Bible of all the
things you can be diagnosed with.
The more you study it,
the more you're like,
I have that.
Oh,
it totally fucking have that.
And you realize everybody has.
Everybody can convince themselves that
they have these.
It's like web md.
You know what I mean?
So it's only once it is sufficient,
lee,
detrimental to your life,
that it affects your relationships.
It affects Your ability to work,
it affects your health,
whatever the case may be,
and usually within the dsm there maybe
like
eight things and it's like you have to
have five out of these eight things and
so anybody can read it and go,
oh,
I've felt depression before,
but what they don't realize is there is
a difference between depression and
sadness.
There's also a difference between parody
depressIon,
so depression that lasts years,
decades,
and the type of depression that people
get that's directly linked to life
events and that's your dog dies,
you will a big one.
You lose your freaking job.
Like we've seen so many documentaries
lately about this.
As the economy took a downturn,
people lose their job and then they
ended up committing suicide because they
can't.
It's like this cascade of awfulness.
That's a really common one.
Um,
you know,
family member dies,
you have a stillborn or you have an
abortion or you how you have a baby,
a healthy baby.
Postpartum depression is incredibly
common.
And in that case,
that's much more common that people can
take meds,
they can do all these things,
and once they get back to where they
were before that horrible life event,
they're okay to get off off the meds.
Some people are able to get their
depression managed without medication
perfectly well,
but some people aren't.
Is the different reactions that
different people have two different
medication?
IS it because their depression has a
different source or is it just a
biodiversity?
I think it's more of a biodiversity
thing than a source thing as sources.
Hard to say.
So depression is both.
When you think about it.
Well,
brain and mind are the same thing in
most modern neuroscientists say that
brain and mind are two sides of the same
coin.
That mind is just an emergent property
of brain.
Nobody's a dualist anymore.
They don't think that you can like heal
the mind and it has no effect on the
brain because it's the same fucking
thing.
So there are some people's depression
comes from the fact that their dopamine
levels are,
are not healthy or their norepinephrine
levels are not healthy or whatever the
fuck.
But I think the,
the common view of depression now is
that there's some sort of biological
difference in your brain and oftentimes
that's either caused or it develops out
of childhood or early life experiences
where you know you have some sort of
trauma or you have some sort of
development.
You have some sort of,
you know,
interaction with famiLy,
whatever the case may be.
And it doesn't have to be,
you know,
you were molested as a child.
It can literally just be like you didn't
feel loved or whatever the case may be.
And you've got this brain difference
combined with this emotional experience
and what ends up happening.
Because when you're very young,
you're brain is very plastic.
So when you're very young,
you're learning skills that are gonna
last you the rest of your life and
you're actually building your brain
architecture.
Certain neurons are connecting and
disconnecting and reconnecting and
pruning out the tree.
The beautiful tree that is all of the
cells in your brain is getting pruned
when you're young and if you're
depressed when you're young and you're
experiencing those kinds of things,
when you're,
you're going to prune a tree that's
prone to depression as you age because
you're going to keep reinforcing those
neuronal connections.
That's why therapy is so important.
Meds in and of themselves are never
going to get you in a place where your
depression is really well managed.
It's going to get you in a place where
therapy is going to be working better
for you.
Meds are going to be an immediate and
necessary interventional strategy so
that you're not crying or you're not
trying to kill yourself or you're not.
Whatever your symptoms so you can
actually fucking get out of bed to work
on yourself.
That's what meds are there for me.
Meds keep me from staying in bed all
day.
That's not variable though.
Finding the right counselor has got to
be incredibly difficult.
It's tough.
It's like I always liken it to the women
who are listening to the podcast.
I liken it unto you when you were first
deciding to go on birth control.
a lot of women will go to their
gynecologist when they're 15,
16,
17 and say,
I want to go on birth control and
they'll give them ortho try cycling or
whatever the pill,
the regular old pill,
and they'll be fine.
A lot of women will take the pill the
first time and it will make them really
sick.
Like every time they take the pill it
makes them want to throw up or it gives
them cramps or something's weird about
it.
It affects others and they go,
oh,
this drug doesn't work for me and go,
oh fuck,
okay,
let's try one with lower levels of
estrogen or progesterone,
or let's try the ring or the depo
provera shot,
or maybe you need an iud.
I was like that.
It took me multiple times to find the
right drug and I think it's the same
thing with therapy.
I think it's the same thing with
psychiatric medicines.
It's not,
we're not monolithic,
so the same combination isn't going to
work for everybody and the truth is if
that makes you afraid of modern medicine
or if it makes you think that psychiatry
is woo or something like that,
it's the same thing as cancer in many
ways.
There's so many parallels.
Cancer is not one disease.
It's a spectrum of diseases.
If I got diagnosed with breast cancer
and you got diagnosed with breast cancer
and we both went in with our diagnosis
the same day,
our oncologists would give us different
treatments because we would have
different genetic markers.
We would respond differently to
different types of chemotherapy.
Chemotherapy means chemical therapy.
It's a really big umbrella term for all
the different kinds of cancer treatments
that are available.
Maybe you would get more radiation.
Maybe I would need surgery,
but your metastasis would make it so
that surgery wasn't a viable option.
It's it's a spectrum.
Disease and psychiatric illness or the
same way.
The variable though,
the counselor has to be kind of weird.
It is weird.
It's weird.
Find someone that you can confide in
wholeheartedly and it takes time a
really long time finding the correct
sex,
right.
Whether or not some men will do better
with women counselors.
I have a male counselor.
I'm like,
I would never.
It's funny,
I have a male therapist,
but I have a female gynecologists like I
would never in a million years let a
dude like put speculums and may and like
dig around in my cervix,
but I'm totally comfortable with a male
therapist.
I have a friend who went through a male
gynecologist and the gynecologist texted
her,
asked her out.
Oh
my gosh.
She's kind of a flirt.
She might've put it out there.
It's crazy.
There.
Reminds me of what's the,
um,
jet appetite.
What's the jed apatow movie while he was
getting in there?
Whenever you have obviously never had a
path you would never know.
I haven't,
but some girls are dirty bitches.
But what's the judd apatow movie with?
Um,
uh,
knocked up,
you know,
and,
and she goes to the doctor and it's her
sister's doctor and he's all like,
oh,
I recognize your now.
Like putting puts her in this.
It's like so good.
I couldn't do dig around your cooter.
I could never.
I just could never.
I'm glad that I live.
I'm glad it's 2014 and there are plenty
of female.
Ob gyn is available because back in the
day you had a male guide.
Yeah,
because they were only do doctors.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That would be really weird for a guy to
have a woman doctor that's checking out
your genitals.
So would be odd as well.
Would you have a female doctor before?
Right?
Like grab your balls while you cough
that.
Yeah,
but that's the issue.
Like the man would be the predator like
that the doctor,
the female doctor would have to deal
with,
especially if it's an attractive female
doctor would have to deal with the dude
being kind of excited about a woman
checking out his balls.
I'm not sure.
Keep doing it.
She found it.
Yeah.
That she'd probably have to deal with
that a bit for fucking sure.
Well,
there's um,
you know,
I was talking to a friend of mount this,
uh,
the other day and he,
is pretty philosophical,
older guy and he was um,
he's been through two divorces and he
was talking about how sex starved so
many people are like,
you're dealing with all these scenarios
where you're like,
oh,
this guy was a creep and this,
you know,
this woman is ridiculous and there are
people out there that no one's touching
and they are so hungry just to be held.
and I mean this is a minor story,
but when I was a,
when I first came to California,
I didn't have any friends,
came here from New York and I wasn't
happy.
I wasn't happy because I didn't enjoy
acting.
I didn't enjoy being around actors and I
didn't have any friends and it wasn't,
didn't have a girlfriend,
didn't have any dates.
And I,
I got a hug from this girl in a set and
I'll never forget that feeling of that
hug because it wasn't like a sexual hug.
It was a friend gave me a hug and when
she gave me the hug it was like my,
my level One but not sexual.
It was like love.
Like I got,
I got touched you.
Gotta love boner.
I got touched for the first time in like
a couple weeks and I was like,
oh,
you need thIs.
Like this is important for people.
It's totally important for people.
There's all sorts of hormones like a
cascade of hormones that you set off
when you are affiliative when you're,
you know,
close to somebody else and it's
absolutely necessary.
And kind of going back to what we were
talking about about aggression,
like a male female difference.
I also feel strongly that many men have
a deep need that slightly different than
than women that our sexual needs are
much more affiliative and emotional and
there is some physiological basis for
female sexual need.
Don't get me wrong,
like any girl can tell you that she's
had this craving,
this,
this passionate feeling where she's
like,
I just need to come or adjust,
need to have sex with somebody.
But with men,
there's literally a backup of fluid that
you have to release.
That's a very different physiological
thing than women.
And again that goes back to
testosterone.
So the same thing as you were saying,
mma can be really helpful for clearing
the mind and for lowering your.
Your base levels of aggression.
I think coming does the same thing.
I think it's healthy for guys to jerk
off if they're not having a lot of sex
because guys can get pent up and be
aggressive because they're not coming up
well.
They're also.
You're desperate to.
Yeah.
I had a joke about it was.
It was a whole descriptive called jerk
off first.
Then think about it like anything you're
thinking about doing in live.
Any weird decision you're gonna make.
You're getting married.
That's good.
Jerk off first.
Then think about,
you know you're going to decide to do
this,
you're going to buy that car.
Are you going to do this?
You're going to buy those clothes.
Jerk off first.
And tell me if you really want to wear
alligator shoes,
what are you?
Why are you wearing those?
So you're trying to attract a certain
person like
about the little head and people guys
thinking with that head or whatever.
There is a really big neurono link
there.
There are hormones that affect your dick
the same way they affect your brain.
And so you can't pretend again that your
cock is somehow completely disconnected
from your emotions,
from your feelings.
Well,
if you at it,
and also if you looked at it
objectively,
if you looked at the human beings on
this planet as like a giant mathematical
equation,
you would say,
okay,
why are there so fucking many of them?
Well,
because there's this intense need to
breed and this intense need to breed was
back when it was really difficult to
stay alive.
You know,
we are essentially the same organism
that used to get cut down by each other
by animals,
predators,
natural illnesses,
disease injuries.
We've only been around for 200,000
years in our,
in our current form,
homo sapiens as a species.
So before 200,000
years ago,
we're talking about something that was
different enough from us,
evolutionarily speaking,
to be a different species.
Homo sapiens,
200,000
years old,
that's long enough for a little bit of
evolution.
Yes,
we are.
We have changed in some ways,
but that's not long enough for that much
evolution in many ways.
Biologically,
psychologically,
evolutionarily speaking.
You're right.
We are the same organism.
That was like crawling out of the trees.
Yeah,
extremely primitive.
And again,
when you also talk about the
biodiversity,
there's some folks that are just more
fucking primitive today,
more animalistic or more kinetic and
just
the range is so massive when we talk
about what is quote normal and what is
hyper and hypo.
So many people are so different and
that's why it's cool to see when people
actually manage to partner up or
whatever sexual or emotional
partnerships make sense for them,
whether they're monogamous or
polygamous,
whether they're um,
you know,
gay,
straight,
somewhere in between.
It's so cool when you see people that
make it work because they're on the same
page when there are so many differences
that exist out there.
When two people go,
you're awesome,
or three or four,
whatever.
And they go,
you're awesome.
I'm into.
You were into the same stuff.
We abide by the same rules.
We have the same sexual proclivities and
it works like how fucking cool is that
because there's so many combinations out
there.
When those magnet,
those two ends of the magnet kind of
find each other in that way,
it's.
It's pretty dope.
Like it's not that common.
Well,
even like when you were talking earlier
about molecules and receptors,
it's almost like you have to have the
right fit.
Yeah,
you totally do.
You also have to be a good molecule.
It's like how many people truly have
their shit together to the point where
anybody would want to be with them and
so many people are so god damn
codependent and so fucked up.
Then they laid can attract anyone
because their own biology,
their psychology though,
the mix that makes them a person,
it's just so chaotic that you can't
expect to be happy in a relationship
because you're not happy alone.
Yeah.
There has to be equity in a
relationship,
like you can't suck the light.
You can't be like a vampire and a
relationship.
You have to offer somebody just as much
as you get from them and you have to be,
like you said,
very standalone.
I mean that's a common theme for me in
therapy is this conversation about if I
am in a relationship,
feeling very confident and comfortable
because I have like an insane fear of
commitment.
I because I'm so used to thinking about
our relationship as if it's a I'm a
prison sentence and I've been really
relearning what it means to be in a
relationship with my therapist and how
the idea of living for now is a
healthier way to look at life.
Like I don't have to think about
hardcore future kinds of conversations.
Like if I'm comfortable with myself
right now and I can be comfortable with
a partner right now and not have all
this like sense of intense obligation.
That's where that codependent stuff
comes from and that's what I think is so
incredibly unhealthy in a relationship.
It's like I'm going to bring my best
self to the table and hopefully I'll
find a partner that does the same thing
instead of needing a partner,
which is a common motivation for people
to get in relationships.
I need somebody else.
I can't handle it on my own.
Well then you're not going to end up
working it out.
There's all those variables to like the
sexual variable,
the emotional variable.
There's so many different things that
are going on and then it's almost like,
okay,
I found this waterhole.
I can't leave.
I finally found water.
I was alone like my experience of going
several weeks without being hugged and
then being hugged and like,
oh,
and that was just a friend.
It was someone on the set.
The difference between that and someone
who's gone years without a relationship
that really worked and you finally have
one that works and you fuck it up
[inaudible] you too.
God damn clingy and too crazy.
Where are you?
Why aren't you home?
I'm texting you,
why aren't you texting me back
immediately?
That kind of shit is what makes me run
out the door.
That's what I'm talking about when I
talk about my quote unquote fear of
commitment.
What it really is is it's an intense
feeling of stress when I feel obligated
to somebody else,
so,
so in the healthiest relationships I've
been in there,
the relationships where there's not a
lot of jealousy,
not a lot of possession,
not a lot of that checking in and it's
just trust.
You trust each other and when you're
really into somebody,
you want to be around them and you spend
time with them,
but when you want to be around your
friends,
they're not like,
where are you?
Why aren't you checking in?
When are you coming home?
It's like,
fuck off dude.
Like I don't want to be with you.
If it's going to be like this,
there are friends like that and they're
brutal and you got to cut them off.
Yeah,
you do because that's.
That's that codependency and what
happens when you end up with two people
were like that with each other and they
less and less learn how to exist on
their own,
so then when they finally do break it
off because it's obviously unhealthy,
then they're fucked.
Then it takes all this healing to get
back to a place where they're
independent again.
Yeah.
That's so true.
And iT's.
It's a weird thing when you find those
two people that like,
they can't be a part.
Like they literally,
they don't go everywhere together.
They roast like nobody wants to be
around them.
They're the worst friends like that,
don't you?
I cut off all my friends.
oh,
you have no friend.
I'm your friend.
fuck face.
What are you talking about?
I mean all my shit friends.
Oh,
you're shit for it.
That's good.
cutting off shit.
Friends is just.
Me and my girl were out there riding
motorcycles.
Well,
I think the older you get,
you just realized why my friends with
these people.
That happens to.
That's true.
When you're younger you need a lot of
support and I think the older you get
the more you value your alone time and
the more you realize that good
relationships and good friendship
shouldn't feel like work and once they
start to feel like work you're like,
fuck,
I have too many obligations and
responsibilities.
I don't want to have to work to be
friends with you.
Also I have a lot of friends that are
like super empowering.
Like when I'm around them I want to do
better.
I want to be better.
I get stimulated,
you know,
I think better my mind functioning like
I'm inspired.
I'm very lucky to have that.
Now.
You know,
you were talking about your experience
when you first came to los angeles and
not having a lot of friends and kind of
being depressed and so when I first
moved to la I was in New York.
I'm usually not that comfortable talking
about this,
but for some reason I'm going through
right now.
I was living in New York and I was
working on my phd and then I started
dating
bill maher.
Like that's why I came to los angeles is
because we started dating,
I was living in New York.
I would kind of come and go and see him
and we weren't committed to each other.
I had a life on the west or on the east
coast.
He had his life here on the west coast
and eventually we got close enough that
we decided,
hey,
let's give this thing a go.
And so I was like,
fuck it.
I was actually really not happy in my
degree program.
so in some ways it was a double whammy.
I was very happy to be exploring a
deeper relationship with this guy that
I'd grown to love and also I was more
and more not happy with my situation in
New York and so it was a new
opportunity.
I moved out to la and we ultimately
ended up dating very seriously for about
three years and that was my,
my first la experience was bizarre as
fuck.
I was dating somebody who was incredibly
famous in the public eye who had a lot
of money.
There was a big equity problem in the
relationship.
I didn't know what I was going to do
with my life.
I had just left my degree program.
I was searching for answers and I was
young.
I was 24,
um,
but I had no friends,
none.
I mean I was friends with people in
their fifties,
like that's,
that was my social circle and yeah,
I would meet people like I would hang
out with sarah silverman,
a little bitter,
but they weren't really my friends.
I was the come along.
I was the girlfriend and there were all
very nice to me and I was like,
what a weird life,
but it was almost like I was living
somebody else's life and I was pretty
depressed and I was very lucky to have
my best friend at the time,
kelly was still living in dallas where I
grew up and I'm kind of worked with her
and hooked her up with a job.
Working with bill.
She ended up becoming his wardrobe
stylist and she still does that to this
day,
which is really amazing.
It was a huge opportunity for her.
She always wanted to come to la.
So.
And now she's this incredible celebrity
stylist and has this great job.
And,
and um,
so I was very lucky when she first came
out maybe six months later because we
got an apartment together and I finally
had somebody,
but I just had her and it took probably
until just a couple of years ago.
So now that's maybe been five years out
before I met this group of friends that
we affectionately call each other.
The nerd brigade.
Yeah.
We hashtag nerd brigade on twitter all
the time and they're like,
one of my best friends just finished her
phd in molecular neuroscience from
caltech.
One of my other best friends got his phd
from usc in animal cognition.
I have a friend who,
another neuroscience student at caltech.
um,
has a marine biology degree.
they're all like science communicators,
writers,
academics,
but cool young,
edgy,
fun people who like,
we get each other,
we're friends because we have a lot in
common.
It took a long time to get close to
these people and to meet them and to
finally.
Because la is a fucking hard city.
If you're used to living in a university
town like there,
it's so hard to you in.
Well first I was in denton,
Texas.
That's where I did my undergrad and my
master's at the university of north
Texas.
And then yeah,
I was in New York city but I was living
in queens specifically in forest hills
because I would take the bus to flushing
every day to um,
to queens college.
That's where I was working on mY phd at
the city,
university of New York graduate center.
But queens college was my campus.
And um,
a lot of my friends live in pasedena
still,
which is very much a college town
because their cow,
they were caltech students and now
they're working there or,
or some of them are still taking
courses.
But I saw,
I mean brian just shook his head like
la,
it's hard to meet smart people in this
city.
It's so full of fucking vapid people and
people who will.
I learned this quickly.
I moved to la dating somebody who was
like an a list celebrity and all of a
sudden I was like,
wait,
why do you want to be friends with me?
Wait,
what's going on?
I also date I dated another very,
very famous person in my life where I
don't,
I don't publicly talk about that
relationship at all just to respect each
other's privacy.
But I wouLd learn things about people.
Like I had this one group of friends who
I thought were my friends,
um,
and I remember dating this person and
being like,
hey,
do you want to come to a barbecue?
I don't know.
Oh,
but you know,
so and so thought that you might want to
play tennis.
We're going to do it at so and so's
house.
Oh,
so and so we'll be there.
Oh yeah.
I'm totally down.
And you would get that all the time.
This like,
oh,
is that why you're friends with me?
Thing is very bizarre.
It's such a weird experience that I
think a lot of people don't.
I never even imagined.
But it also has opened a million doors
for me.
Like how the fuck you think when I was
23 years old,
you know,
cutting up mice or birds and digging
around in their brains.
See,
I always thought I was going to be a
bench scientist and that's what I was
going to do and I kind of hated it.
I loved teaching,
kind of hated doing the lab work,
but I was like,
okay,
this is the path I'm on and this is who
the fuck.
If somebody had told me,
oh,
you're going to be in media,
you're going to be on the joe rogan
podcast,
you're going to start your own podcast.
You're going to be on television.
I'd be like,
you're fucking out of your mind.
Like I'm scared of camp.
When I was in Texas at 16,
I tried out for season two of american
idol.
You sing?
Yeah.
I was a jazz singer and qa.
And so I made it through for callbacks
and season two american idol.
I made it through the producers,
the executive producers more.
ExActly.
I finally got to the three judges.
Who were they?
The main ones?
It was like randy and paula and simon
cow.
And um,
so that was the last audition you do
before you have the book.
Right.
And you know why I didn't get it.
All three of them said like,
you're not,
they go,
we'd like your voice.
We like your look because I was a total
punk rock kid.
I had short spiky hair and my lip ring
and the arm is very avril levine,
kind of a look back then.
And they were like,
oh,
we love it all your,
you're the total package.
And I was like,
great.
And then I auditioned and they were
like,
you're not going through.
No,
but why?
And they were like,
you are not tv ready.
I was so afraid of the cameras.
I like didn't have that dynamic
personality that all of the reality tv
stars have where they're like,
I'm going to win this competition
because I'm the best.
I just walked up and I was like,
are you ready for me to say I'm so
scared?
Like it was I,
I was weak.
I didn't have that,
that kind of self assertive thing going
on to develop that.
I think I did.
I think it happened from getting thrown
into it.
I think what happens is when you're
like,
okay,
I'm just working.
I met him in the lab also.
I taught between then and now I've
taught like a million courses so that
helps you stand up in front of a
classroom and you go,
you don't understand glycolysis,
we're going to figure this out together,
up on the whiteboard and you're helping
the students.
So that helps with your confidence for
sure.
But also I think getting thrown into it.
I come to la and it's like,
oh,
let's go to the emmys.
Let's walk this red carpet,
let's do all.
And then you know,
you're all the sudden in the room with
all these really important people and
you don't even know who they are.
Like I would go to parties where every
single person there was a celebrity and
the people you didn't recognize,
you didn't recognize because they owned
movie studios.
Like it's the weirdest feeling and then
once you realize I'm not that different
from these people,
I can have a conversation with them like
anyone else and I would talk about
science,
I'd be like,
science is awesome.
Let me tell you this story.
And they'd go,
oh,
that's kInd of interesting.
And then eventually bill was like,
you need to be doing this on television,
you need to be trying this at least
because I think you'd be good at it.
He completely and utterly pushed me into
this and I thank him everyday for it
because I never would have done it
without his help.
When the depression started when I was a
child.
So you were dealing with it your whole
lot?
My whole life.
Oh completely.
Some of those years,
like when I was dating bill or when I
would be moving,
those were some of the worst years
because it was so stressful because he
didn't have friends because I was
unmedicated unmedicated then.
Yeah.
I didn't start taking medication until
about three years ago.
About 27.
Did you try other methods to try?
I tried some things and I,
I've been in therapy my whole life.
My parents first put me in therapy when
they first started to decide that they
were thinking about getting a divorce
and I was a young man.
I was maybe six or seven,
so from the time I remember I've
understood the therapeutic process and
they always really promoted that in me.
so then even after the divorce and the
re marriages and all of that,
I started doing the,
the,
the therapy thing on my own.
Then when I went to college and I was
very much on my own,
I went to college when I was 16,
by the way.
I've lived on my own at 60.
I was fucking weird kid.
Yeah,
so I was a little.
I'm an adult,
but I wasn't.
I did that.
I went to therapy.
I did all those things by myself,
but I always had this mental block.
I always had this like,
oh,
I don't need meds.
meds means you're really crazy.
Meds means you really don't have control
and not until I kind of hit a very bad
rock bottom a few,
maybe three years ago did I finally say,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I've,
I think I actUally have to do this.
I think it would be good for me.
And then it was the same experience that
I've heard over and over and over from
people were finally they get on the meds
that are right for them and they
calibrate to their dosage and maybe
they've been on it for about two months
and they just have this epiphany of
like,
why the fuck did I wait so long?
I could have felt like this my whole
life.
What the fuck was I thinking?
Because you're so societaly,
we're so resistant to looking at mental
illness the same way we look at physical
illness where,
so it's so easy.
Uh,
paul gil martin just made this point
when he was on my podcast last week.
If you went up to somebody with diabetes
type one diabetes and you were like,
what the fuck dude,
why don't you just think more positively
so that your pancreas makes insulin?
Like what?
What's wrong with you?
Why can't you just make more insulin?
It's like they'd be like,
what are you talking about?
It's the same thing with depression.
People put the onus on you like they,
they look at it like it's a disease of
will,
but it's not.
It's a,
it's a biological illness and that's
just very hard for people to understand
and so what you end up doing is carrying
around a lot of guilt and shame and a
lot of feelings like,
I'm not good enough.
I can't will myself out of this if I
just think more positively.
It's not about that,
and I did that for years,
years.
You just deal with it and I destroyed so
many relationships.
Wow.
yeah.
I can only imagine.
I can only imagine being trapped in that
scenario,
but I'm.
I'm also very sensitive to the variables
that different people go through with
their bodies.
I have hypothyroidism.
I have to take thyroid medication.
It runs in my family,
my mother has it too,
and I know I used to get headaches,
these weird headaches at the end of the
day where I was like,
oh fuck,
like I could fall asleep.
And it wasn't like,
it wasn't like I was like,
now I get tired,
I go to sleep,
but it was like I could fall asleep just
watching tv and be out for like an hour.
So it didn't make any sense.
It was like a weird tired,
like I was in pain,
so,
uh,
and I get these weird headaches.
And then once I finally got on
medication I was like,
whoa,
yeah,
right.
you're like,
oh,
this is,
this is what other people feel like,
like I thought I was normal because
that's another thing.
There's such a stigma in this country,
not just about mental illness but about
any sort of illness where people can't
openly freely talk about it.
So you end up living in this weird
bubble where you don't really like,
I know people that have mental illness
that didn't even realize they had mental
illness until they finally had a
conversation with a doctor about it and
they were like,
oh,
this isn't normal.
Like everybody doesn't hear voices or
everybody doesn't.
It's like,
yeah,
because you're so afraid to talk to
somebody about it.
So that's,
I mean that's a really important part of
this I think is just getting past the
stigma.
That's why when something like this with
robin williams,
which is so fucking depressing happens a
lot of people rally around it and they
say,
hey,
maybe we can use this as a teaching
moment because this guy,
no matter how good his life was,
he had this thing that he ultimately
couldn't kick and it wasn't his fault.
It just
is that way sometimes.
And hey,
maybe you have it too.
I think in some ways it's good when high
functioning People come out and talk
about their illnesses because then
people who are actually experiencing
things like loss of employment,
loss of a loved one,
whatever,
or who have had a bad go of it for other
reasons or like even you,
like you had said before,
like even you,
but you're pretty or,
but you're successful,
you're whatever.
Well,
if you could have that,
then of course it's not weird that I
have,
you know,
it's like it's a good thing for people
to be able to see that they're not alone
like that.
And also there's a bunch of people that
attribute other people's depression
really irresponsibly to a bunch of
different things.
Oh yeah.
I had gotten the podcast last week that
was saying that robin williams killed
himself because his wife's ex wives took
all his money as if he knows it all.
It's like,
oh,
I'm so glAd you're such an expert and
I'm not saying that it was a women's
addiction to free stuff that was loose.
It was so horrible and it makes you want
to be like,
who the fuck are you to presume that you
know what's happening in somebody else's
head ever?
Not only that,
it's insanely you're responsible to go
against the grain of science and
medicine,
which is clearly established that it's
an illness.
It's an illness.
Yeah,
and I think that that's something too
that a lot of people don't understand
the same way.
We're so comfortable with concepts of
diagnosis and cure because we're so used
to things like flu cold,
um,
you know,
tonsil infection,
whatever,
where you take an antibiotic or you take
an antiviral or you just wait in your
immune system clears the disease.
We're used to catching things and then
eliminating them.
But when you have disease states that
are processed,
states like cancer,
like diabetes,
like mental illness,
there's no cure per se.
like I even,
I got a tweet just earlier today from
somebody who is like,
blah,
blah.
Have you ever thought about blah,
blah,
blah to cure your depression?
It's like,
I'm not cured of depression because I
take attallah pram,
I'm in treatment puts.
I'll be in treatment the rest of my
life.
Do you believe as a person who's a
neuroscientist,
is it possible that they could
eventually come up with something that
balances your brain out instead of just
adding something to your neurochemistry,
which sort of enhances your serotonin
levels,
but rather something that where they can
get it at a genetic level?
I hope so.
I mean,
I really hope so.
We're starting to see major improvements
in cancer biology with personal genomic
medicine.
My fear with genomic medicine is only
not to put a dark cloud on it because I
think that it has like amazing
prospects.
My fear is that it's going to further
increase the kind of class divide where
you've got people who are sick because
sickness strikes rich and poor the same,
but for some reason we are a very class
based system
and I think that you're going to see
that rich people get those kinds of
treatments and poor people don't and
that that kind of stuff
scares me.
That worries me.
It always is with anything emerging
technologies.
Remember in the old days,
the wall street phone,
remember that wall street movie where
Michael Douglas epic fucking stupid
phone and that was like a huge status
symbol.
Rappers used to happen videos,
most people couldn't afford a phone.
Now I,
I go to Brazil all the time for the ufc
and I've gone to these poor
neighborhoods.
You see people on cell phones.
Oh,
you see it in,
in african nations were there aren't,
there isn't enough malaria medication,
but I mean there's this huge malaria,
um,
push right now to increase awareness and
you know,
you can get mosquito nets,
you can do malaria tests on your family
and you do it all through your cell
phone because it's very common for
people to have cell cell service or
maybe not service,
but to have access to a cell phone
because the technology is getting
cheaper and cheaper.
So yes,
I do think that time always tells and
that hopefully eventually that kind of
stuff trickles down.
but I wish it didn't have to trickle
down.
I wish medication.
I wish health and wellness,
we're a more egalitarian enterprise that
one of the biggest problems I think with
the structure of american government and
being such a capitalist society,
which I'm all about capitalism,
don't get me wrong,
I think we need to be a socialist
capitalist blend just like we are.
Um,
we have a lot of socialist systems in
our country.
The male,
the socialist educate,
public education is socialist.
We have a lot of capitalist systems in
this country.
I hate that healthcare is a for profit
system in America.
It makes no sense to me.
The argument is obviously the people who
work harder or more ambitious become
better at it,
should be rewarded for that.
And that's what's going to motivate them
to work harder and be the best heart
surgeon to be the best brain doctor to
be the best.
You know,
the guy who fixes.
I just feel like by the time you're a
brain surgeon and you're licensed brain
surgeon,
you're a fucking good brain surgeon like
you.
You don't get through a 10 year
residency.
You get your surgical degree and then
you have a 10 year residency before you
become a neurosurgeon.
You don't get through that and you're
like a sub par neurosurgeon.
You're,
you're a fucking incredible
neurosurgeons.
they're the best of the best,
the best of the best.
And if those people want to do private
practice on top of it,
that's fine,
but we have a practice on top of the
socialized medicine.
There has to be a national health
service.
Has to be.
I agree with that.
Here's the problem.
Fundamentally and I,
it's very.
If you can provide me an argument that
solves this problem for a capitalist
healthcare system,
then I'm all about too,
and I don't mean you,
but I mean anybody listening,
I'm all about hearing it.
The problem is that when you have a
capitalist system that's a competition
based system for profit,
what ends up happening is that people
compete.
That's how it works,
right?
You compete in,
a lot of times they say that's what
drives prices down,
is that you compete and prices get
better and then you've,
you know,
the best part,
whatever.
Um,
but what ends up happening when you have
for profit healthcare is that illness is
incentivized.
Wellness is not.
People make more money.
The sicker you get,
people make more money.
The more procedures you have to get.
People make more money,
the longer you stay in the hospital and
the minute.
I'm not saying there's some grand
conspiracy to keep people sick,
but if you've got an industry like the
insurance and pharmaceutical and for
profit hospital industry where the
profit comes from sickness,
where is the incentive to get people?
Well,
I'm not saying that doctors aren't very
noble people.
They are and they work every day.
DoctorS,
nurses,
other healthcare officials to get people
better.
But the system in itself does not
incentivize wellness.
It incentivizes sickness.
So at that very basic level,
it's a bit broken because somewhere
along that chain people are gonna take
advantage.
They're going to say,
oh,
I make more money if this guy has to
stay in the hospital an extra day or I
make more money if this guy has to get
this quote unquote unnecessary procedure
all the way across the board.
The sicker you are,
the more money goes into the system and
that's really gross.
It's gross.
There are certain things that capitalism
don't work on and I think that wellness,
which is a basic human right,
is one of those things.
It just doesn't make sense.
it's fundamentally incompatible with
that type of monetary system,
but isn't that just taking into account
only people that do the wrong thing,
but people who do the right thing,
who motivate themselves to become the
best orthopedic surgeon and treat the
lakers and fix all their knee issues and
these people rise to the occasion,
shouldn't they be rewarded totally.
And the turd in the pool is not the
surgeon.
Trust me,
it's the insurance company.
It's the pharmaceutical company.
It's this.
Occasionally the surgeon.
I have a friend who was my friend rob
when he was young,
worked at a resort and he.
He clearly remembers these doctors
bragging about how they talked to some
guy into getting a surgery and because
of these buying a porsche.
Yeah,
no,
there is that.
oh,
for sure.
So,
so the fact that it even trickles down
to the people who took a hippocratic
oath to the people who we think of as
being the most noble of the most noble
of citizens in this country,
if it even trickles down to them,
how is it going to affect somebody who's
pushing paper at the insurance company
where you're just a number on a piece of
paper,
you're just a statistic and you're a
bottom line is the answer to cut out
that aspect of it,
that the insurance company is the,
the the issue and that really socialized
medicine would be compensating the
doctors and the doctors would still be
potentially able to rise.
That would be my answer is the same.
I think as any other industrialized
western nation.
We're the only industrialized western
nation that doesn't have national
healthcare,
so what ends up happening is you have a
public option.
You have the option to have a healthcare
system that is free and available to you
and it has basic levels of treatment and
care for anything that could go wrong
with you and their doctors.
You can see in their hospitals.
You can go to if you want to go private.
It's the same way that we have education
in this country.
I had an amazing public education.
I have friends who went to private
school.
Their parents wanted them to go to
private school.
Good for them.
They may have had a better education
than me.
They may not have because there were
still amazing teachers available and an
incredible infrastructure in place for
me to get an incredible education as a
student in the right spot or you can be
in the la unified school system and have
fucking horrible education that that is
a problem with gentrification and with
segregation and with again,
I think some of the problems of our
capitalist society.
While it's certainly a problem in how we
view and what you know,
what we think about in terms of where
our money should go.
LIke if we had.
We had privatized police force and
privatized fire.
Like every time your house was on fire,
you had to pay someone to come in and
fix the issue and put the fire out.
Like,
my god,
it's happened before it's happened
there.
Yeah.
You can find stories online of people
living in,
in regions where they have like a
privatized,
um,
fire service,
like it's a,
a four pay fire service and like
people's houses have burned down because
they can't afford to put it out a weird
area.
Like some,
like some rural area.
Exactly.
And imagine what that was an urban issue
with healthcare.
I mean healthcare.
You can be in the biggest,
most populated city in the world and
there's poor people that don't have
healthcare.
Yeah.
I think that if society is going to
offer basic services,
police force and fire for fire
departments,
medicine has got to be wanting to be one
of them.
And the thing is when you put the money
into preventive care that's necessary,
you end up saving so much money on the
back end when people who can't afford to
go to the doctor until they have a
festering wound or until they've allowed
the cancer to spread or whatever are
going to the doctor early on and they're
getting a checkup because they can
afford it because it's free to them.
When you've got somebody who's living on
the street who obviously going to be
subject to much more infection,
much more disease because they just,
they're living in squalor.
If they can go to the doctor on a
regular basis and get a checkup,
they're not going to be then going to
the doctor later to get some multi
thousand dollar procedure.
That hippocratic oath,
they have to do this.
If somebody goes into and they're like,
fucking arm is hanging off,
no doctor is going to be like,
I can't reattach your arm.
You're just going to die.
They're going to do it.
They're going to build these people and
they're never gonna fucking pay their
bills because they can't afford to and
then you and I are going to absorb that
cost in our.
In the money that we're paying for our
insurance.
Go back when you're talking about people
living in squalor.
That goes back to the mental illness
issue as well because
he definitely massive percent of those
people that are wandering around
homeless.
They're such an important point to make,
but that was the gun.
Damn.
Ronald reagan administration,
they changed the standards.
They let loose,
I remember it,
I was a kid and I remember being in New
York and seeing all these fucking people
wandering.
I came to New York for a martial arts
tournament during the reagan
administration and I remember like
people were talking and I was young.
I was a teenager and these adults were
talking about these that all of a sudden
they changed the mental health standards
and they were releasing all these people
and I was like,
what?
LIke they're just releasing them.
They were taking these people that were
in mental institutions.
They changed the standards of what you
needed to to keep these people in these
facilities and they were just released
them on the streets and influx.
There were two massive releases.
There was one in the fifties when held
all first came on the market,
which is an anti psychotic,
which was a major improvement and
psychiatric care.
So all of a sudden you had people who
were schizophrenic,
who had delusional kind of disorders and
you can treat them.
And so these people who were like
basically just being fed and watered and
asylums were given how doll and they
could lead functional lives again.
So there you saw a big change in the way
that mental health services happened.
You,
you no longer had the asylum population
and then you started having more of this
idea of like a mental health facility.
And then again,
during the reagan administration used,
you saw a big release.
The problem there was,
it was,
it was really a name only.
They weren't getting any better
treatment.
They were just put out on the street,
change the standard.
Exactly.
And so you've got these people that are
put out on the street and it's,
it's again,
that there's,
don't get me wrong,
I,
I mean,
look at me like I,
like I said,
I moved out when I was fucking 16.
I busted my ass my whole life to like
work really hard.
I got a good education.
Um,
I,
you know,
even coming to la with bill,
he opened a bunch of doors for me.
I fucking walk through those doors.
I made sure that I was as responsible as
possible.
I am all about fiscal and personal
responsibility.
I have amazing credit,
I have no debt.
Um,
but I also know that as a nation we're
only as strong as the weakest amongst us
and there are certain people to whom
those types of standards just can't
apply because they're,
they're ill will.
It's a spectrum issue,
isn't it?
I mean there's,
there's so many variables that when,
when people like to look at these issues
and look at them in a black and white
term,
I'm a liberal.
So I think this,
I'm a conservative.
So I think that.
And that's really,
you know,
I have a lot of ideas that are very
liberal and a lot of ideas that are
fairly conservative too.
There's a real issues with picking aside
like that,
especially when it comes to ideologies.
It's just such a lazy way to think.
You're not thinking,
you're letting somebody else think for
you.
I get a lot of hate when I come on your
podcast,
but also when I go on the young turks,
anytime I talk about gm foods or
genetically modified crops in any way
and because what ends up happening is
people look at me and they go,
oh,
you're a liberal shill.
They say,
I'm a shell.
They look at me and they say,
okay,
you're a liberal,
you're a progressive,
you're left wing.
Why do you have this super conservative
ideology when it comes to gm foods?
Why would you say that you thInk that's
a good thing?
You must be pro big agribusiness.
You must be pro monsanto and it's like,
because I don't inform my politics based
on what a party tells me,
my politics are informed based on the
science.
I studied the science behind genetic
modification and I come to a personal
conclusion that genetic modification in
and of itself is not only not dangerous,
but can also be a huge boon.
It can be really helpful for health and
human safety across,
especially in lower income and
globalized areas where they're not very
industrialized.
Second problem is that people have a
really hard time with the concept of sin
touchy.
This idea of,
you know,
that's a literary term for looking at
the part for the whole or the whole for
the part.
So people say gm food,
monsanto,
monsanto.
It's the same thing.
It's not the fucking same thing.
That's a company that utilizes gm
technology and yes,
recently I got offered a branded
entertainment job with monsanto and I
had to turn it down and the reason I
turned it down was not necessarily
because I really disagree with the
practices even though I do fucking
disagree with their practices.
Like let's be honest.
There are a lot of monsanto things that
make me mad.
Social practices are but in the
capitalist kind of prep,
but.
But the reason I had to turn down this
brand to deal is because I knew that if
I ever took a dime from a company like
monsanto,
my ability as a journalist to talk about
gm crops from a very neutral perspective
would be out the window.
Nobody would ever take me seriously
again.
So it's the same thing with big pharma.
People go like a big pharma's evil,
and it's like,
so what should you never take drugs
again?
Are you out of your fucking mind?
It's like you've got to be able to look
at these things in a nuanced way and
understand that there are problems and
there are evils,
but you can't throw the baby out with
the bathwater and you can't say,
oh,
all modern medicine is terrible because
pfizer is making money on the backs of
poor people.
It's like,
yeaH,
that's fucked up about pfizer,
but that doesn't mean modern medicine is
terrible.
These are two totally different
conversations.
AlSo people,
when they start talking about
genetically modified foods,
one of the things that they have to take
into consideration is that almost
everything you eat is genetically
modified and you go to the grocery
store.
If you're getting corn,
if you're getting apples,
if you're getting tomatoes,
stop thinking that this just because
it's organic,
that it's not genetically modified.
The corn that you eat today has no
resemblance to the original corn.
None Whatsoever,
and then they'll say,
yeah,
but it might not be transgenic.
It likely is transgenic too,
and that's another thing like genetic
modification is a really big umbrella
term.
It could be selective breeding is
genetic modification with a lot of
people have a hard time with the concept
of transgenic foods and I say to them,
fine,
if you don't want to eat transgenic,
food's good.
Define transgender.
So transgenic foods would be a scientist
going into the genome of an organism.
Let's say it's a type of corn.
They go into the genome and they go,
okay,
this corn tends to die readily.
When the temperature gets above 101,
well the climate is changing.
It's getting hotter and hotter Where
they farm it,
so we're going to tinker with the genome
and we're going to delete a gene or
insert a gene or move the genes around
in some way so that this corn is now
drought resistant.
Change the genome,
produce a new corn crop,
and then continue to breed that corn
crop and that is really the goal and
generally the motivation behind gm
crops.
It's to make them withstand things like
droughts or pests or whatever,
so that they can live heartier and feed
more people in that way.
Now sometimes you have a company like
monsanto doing their own research where
they want to make a crop that can only
live for one generation and then die so
that farmers have to keep buying their
seeds,
for example,
or they make a roundup ready crops.
I want to crop so that I can spray the
whole thing down.
With roundup,
the crop survives,
but all of the weeds around it die.
It's an easier way to farm,
but it could have some really
detrimental ecological effects,
but for the most part,
this is why a lot of scientists get
pissed off about all the gm hysteria
because they're like,
okay,
if I were to take this random corn crop
and that random corn crop and breed
them,
I'm shuffling like 30,000
genes.
If I were to go in targeted and changed
three genes that only affect the ability
for it to withstand a higher
temperature.
It's a much more specific and targeted
way to change this plant.
I trust it more.
I know exactly what I'm eating,
but people are like,
oh,
it's horrifying because they're going in
with,
you know,
pipetters and tools.
Well,
it's because of things like roundup
because of companies that do mean
there's a reason why people are
suspicious is reason why people are
cautious,
they are worried about.
And then there's been also some.
There's been some fuckery involved in
these studies too.
Like there's a study about rats where
they showed the grow,
grew all these tumors in rats.
They use more susceptible to tumors in
the first place.
it's not,
it's,
you know,
what,
as somebody,
as a person who has never studied lab
science to try and make sense of all the
bullshit in the media and,
and,
and to be reading articles that were
written by journalists who have never
studied lab on,
how are you expected to keep things
straight?
That's why I do what I do for a living.
I'm a science communicator and my job is
to look at research that exists and to
try and translate that to the public.
But I also want to try and understand
where the public is coming from.
Why are you afraid of this thing?
Why does this thing worry you?
Let's understand the psychological
reasons behind it.
LeT's understand what you've been fed
your hold lives by the media and see
what's reasonable and what's not and
come to a rational conclusion about it.
Unfortunately,
we as a species respond better in some
ways to fear and hysteria.
We we see on the news that's like,
holy shit,
this thing could kill you,
and you're like,
oh my god,
really?
I need to know about this.
Because if the media was always
presenting things rationally like,
okay,
let's take a balanced approach to this.
Let's look at the pros and the cons and
people would tune out.
It's not that interesting anymore.
The things that we find salient are the
things that raise the hairs on the backs
of our necks and what that ends up
breeding is,
you know,
is just a media landscape of
fearmongering and screaming matches and
worst case scenario conversations,
which I don't think is very helpful for
anybody.
It's also the reality of the absorption
of information that people's ability to
take in.
How,
I mean,
how much time do you have in a day?
People work eight plus hours a day plus
commuting plus family,
plus you have to be an expert about
whatever they do for a living.
I doN't know,
contradicting information.
You could always go online and find a
host of websites that will tell you
about the evils of genetically modified
foods and if and if you absorb that
information and you.
That is what you preach,
that's your mantra.
Now.
It's very difficult to be open minded
and then sort of accept other ideas and
try that,
contradict those original ideas that
you've been telling everybody about
and in.
The truth is it's,
it's,
it's hard to figure out who to trust,
especially in a landscape like this.
That's why I never promote.
I have no intention as a science
communicator that the work that I do is
going to necessarily promote a lot of
people to go off and become scientists
themselves.
I mean hopefully young,
young children or some Teens,
people who are in that,
in that age group and who are
interested.
Maybe there'll be influenced a little
bit about some of the work that I do,
but more more than that,
I want to see a higher level of
scientific literacy in this country.
All that means is that we think more
with our brains and less with our
emotions and less with our,
you know,
that stephen colbert truthiness,
like we got to get away from truthiness
just because something feels right
doesn't necessarily mean that it is
right.
So it's like,
stop for a minute,
listen to the argument that's being
made.
Who is making the argument?
Do they have any financial reason to be
making the argument?
Did they have any political reason to
meet making the argument is this,
is this article about gmos being evil on
a website called,
oh my god,
gmos are evil.com
or you know,
and,
and that's the thing.
And I,
I,
and,
and I think this also goes back to this
conversation I had about throwing the
baby out with the bathwater.
The mainstream media has its problems,
but journalism is an enterprise has a
lot of nobility to it.
The pharmaceutical company has major
problems and it's very broken the
insurance company too,
but medicine has so much worth to it
especially,
you know,
evidence based by biomedical advances.
Psychiatric medicine has a lot of know
pluses.
The process of genetic modification is
so important,
but yes,
monsanto has a lot of problems.
We've got to be able to think more
nuanced about these things and instead
of going,
well,
I don't trust fox news,
therefore I don't trust any media.
Therefore I only am going to go to the
site.
Did that keeps,
as you said,
reinforcing what I already believe.
Omg,
gmos are horrible.com.
That's the only place where I get my
news.
Well now you're in an echo chamber.
That's a huge issue and the other thing
that you brought up there about
political,
about financial,
all the different motivations,
all the different things in the
variables,
that's also stuff that you have to try
to pay attention to and squeeze into
your head and that's the thing that it's
impossible.
We need someone like you to sort of
break it down.
Someone who has a background in this
particular area to break it down in a
way that we can understand what go.
Okay,
I'm comfortable.
The santa maria is being honest with me
about this particular aspect of
depression and neurochemistry.
He theSe are.
This is her experience.
This is also what she knows about the
science behind it.
Okay.
I have no motivation otherwise.
Nobody's paying me to say this and I
think that this is why we,
as you know,
the listeners of the joe rogan
experience,
the listeners of talk nerdy with carrie,
santa maria,
the people who are really involved in
the next movement of alternative and new
media.
It is our responsibility to continue to
support these kinds of programs and to
continue to speak up and become engaged
and involved.
Because if we're not happy with the way
that traditional media is handling
things because they're playing to the
ratings and they're playing to the
lowest common denominator,
we can't be passive about it.
We have to support the news outlets and
the organizations and the podcasts and
the web shows that that we support.
We have to do our part to make sure that
those things don't fail because the
unfortunate thing is we don't have the
backers that they have.
You know,
I have a squarespace on my side.
I have computer learning zone on my
side.
You have these wonderful,
uh,
sponsors on your side that help you keep
doing this so that you can offer it for
free to your listeners,
but we're not being backed by pfizer,
but we don't have four months and we
don't have to meet with these other
companies would find value in it and
they know that we're going to say some
crazy shit,
but the only reason they're going to
keep supporting us if is if people keep
listening and if you raise them where
people are going to keep listening
because it's interesting.
And the only reason why it's interesting
is because we're being honest.
Yes.
And so that,
that whole chain,
like we're all in it together.
I think that's the important thing is
that like,
we're here for you,
you're here for us.
And we're all on that same team to be
that counterculture and to,
to offer opinions.
But also offer facts that are,
that are based in evidence that are
based in reason,
that aren't based in some sort of
corporate interest or because some
producer is in that fucking thing in my
ear telling me that I have to do or say
or act like somebody that I'm not.
I would love to talk to you about this
to the end of time.
I would love to not tell you that you're
already past the time you were supposed
to leave.
You know what's so funny too is the
reason I have to leave and I'm so sorry
you guys is because I have therapy
therapy at three
and I've got to make it all the way
across town to see my therapist at
anytime you want to do this,
I'm more than happy to with you and I'm
so happy you're doing your show.
thank you so much for wearing my tee
shirt.
I have to.
Can I take a moment to plug?
Is that okay?
Because I just started making all this
great merchandise and you can find it if
you go brian to my main website just to
care.
Like if you go home,
maybe click on home,
then you can see that I've got all of my
episodes right there.
You can download them into the center.
That was on a different page.
it was an old episode that I did a talk
nerdy to me,
but there's,
you know,
you can see my episodes of the podcast
right there.
I use soundcloud,
so it's through there.
And then if you scroll down you can see
all of my merchandise there.
I have t shirts and stickers and slap
bracelets.
This one just like that one.
The old school microphone.
I'm going to have a new style coming out
soon and also I'm going to be offering
soon hand made mugs from a really
amazing potter friend of mine.
So those will be really cool.
Custom one of a kind.
Mugs are made in a fucking factory in
China by slaves,
but they're beautiful.
They're pretty cool.
well it's Mike Maxwell,
Mike Maxwell,
the artist.
I really like it.
It's cool.
And I get to take this home,
right?
Oh yeah.
Fuck yeah.
I've run jre cups now too,
and if you guys want to buy them,
they're available@higherprimate.com.
Thank you very much,
kara.
Thank you for your podcast is awesome.
I always love talking to you.
It's just a.
It's always just trying to catch up with
your thought process and stuff it all in
there,
But I appreciate it very much.
Thank you so much.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please check out our podcast.
It's amazing character.
Tweet me at carolina.
Maria,
out of her.
Um,
anything else before we go?
You have anything going on?
People need new t shirts.
You fucking talk to the back of
microphones.
40 t shirts@shopsquad.tv.
Come into columbus,
Ohio with tony and Tiffany Harris and
all that
mission is on desk squad.tv.
Go there,
check it out and thank you to our
sponsors.
Thank you.
Today to ziprecruiter,
ziprecruiter.com.
Go to ziprecruiter.com
forward slash rogen and you can post
jobs for free.
Give it a shot.
Ziprecruiter.com.
Thanks.
Also to nature box to nature box.com
forward slash rogen and get 50 percent
off your first box and thanks also to on
it.
Go to o,
n n I t use the codeword rogan.
Save 10 percent off any and all
supplements.
All right,
you'd already.
Fox will see you tomorrow.
Big kiss.